Das war's für heute.
<<<<<<< Updated upstream
So, ahem, bin ich am Start.
Late Stream, na ja, es geht erst um 22 Uhr richtig los.
=======
So, bin ich am Start.
Late Stream, naja es geht erst um 22 Uhr richtig los.
>>>>>>> Stashed changes
Die Musik ist ein wenig MonkaS, das stimmt. Was ist das?
Pokémon Ultra Sun und Ultra Moon Battle.
<<<<<<< Updated upstream
Aha, nachdem ich wenig Pokémon spiele, habe ich keinen Plastinshimmer von der Pokémon Musik.
=======
>>>>>>> Stashed changes
Das letzte Teil soll aber nicht gut gewesen sein, habe ich gelesen.
Den haben alle geflamed. Alle gesagt, Nintendo hat's verkackt.
Was Nintendo-Fans natürlich nicht gerne hören.
Weil...
Wenn's nach Nintendo-Fans geht, ist ja Nintendo mehr oder weniger unfehlbar.
Warum sieht mein Kanal so komisch aus gerade?
Mein Kanal sieht voll kaputt aus, was ist denn da los?
Ah, das ist das neue Design, verstehe.
Ich will doch einfach nur eine Vorschau mir angucken.
<<<<<<< Updated upstream
Warum... Ich habe jetzt mal eine ernst gemeinte Frage.
Warum werden, wenn neue Designs gemacht werden, sei es Twitch, YouTube, Reddit, sonst was,
warum werden die nicht intuitiver gemacht?
Also warum wird nicht das genommen, was man hat, und verbessert die Bereiche, was die Leute nervt,
anstatt so komische Dinge zu machen, wo man jetzt fünfmal klicken muss, im Vergleich zu vorher einmal?
=======
Warum, ich habe jetzt mal eine ernst gemeinte Frage.
Warum werden, wenn neue Designs gemacht werden, sei es Twitch, YouTube, Reddit, sonst was.
Warum werden die nicht intuitiver gemacht?
Also warum wird nicht das genommen, was man hat und verbessert die Bereiche, was die Leute nervt.
Anstatt so komische Dinge zu machen, wo man jetzt fünfmal klicken muss, im Vergleich zu vorher einmal.
>>>>>>> Stashed changes
Ich meine, guckt euch das mal an.
Wir gehen jetzt mal auf Twitch.
<<<<<<< Updated upstream
Wenn ich jetzt meine Clips angucken will...
=======
Wenn ich jetzt meine Clips angucken will.
>>>>>>> Stashed changes
So.
Dann geht jetzt erstmal hier mein Stream auf.
Ich mute mich mal, sonst bin ich dreimal...
Also jetzt ruckelt's mich sauer.
Dann geht mein Stream auf.
<<<<<<< Updated upstream
So, und jetzt ist... Okay, wo finde ich jetzt meine Clips?
Jetzt muss man wissen, man muss wissen, es ist kein Indikator dafür.
Man muss auf dieses, auf das Avatar klicken, dass man überhaupt das Menü bekommt dafür.
Das weiß man nicht.
Also es gibt keiner Indikator dafür.
Das ist mega schlechtes UI-Design irgendwie.
So, und wenn man das weiß, aus dem Ruck, wie gesagt, die Seite ruckelt wie Sau.
Guckt es euch an.
So, dann geht man auf Videos.
Dann geht man hier oben hin auf Featured Clips.
Das ist total umständlich.
Warum trenntet meine... Warum trenntet er was mit der Katze?
Oder was er trenntet?
So ist die Katze nachgemacht, aber Alter.
Das ist fast schon Windows-Menüführung.
Ach Gott, und Michael 50 Billionen ist auch am Start.
Also es geht, ich denke mal, dass es kurz vor 22 Uhr losgeht.
Mit irgendwie Pre-Show oder sonst was.
Offiziell um 22 Uhr.
Schreiben sie auch hier 95 Minuten, eineinhalb Stunden.
Gucken wir mal.
Schauen wir mal, also.
Genau, genau, Emix Risen.
Ich verstehe den Sinn nicht davon, warum man das jetzt 5 Mal klicke muss, wo vorher einmal ging.
Und eins muss man ja mal sagen, also.
Die Twitch-Webseite.
Die war jetzt noch nie irgendwie die absolute Augenweide.
Es ist jetzt nicht so, dass ich auf Twitch gegangen bin.
Boah, ist das eine tolle, toll designte Experience hier.
Ist das toll und sonst was.
Aber Twitch war eigentlich relativ zweckmäßig.
Das neue Design macht es nicht hübscher, aber auch nicht wirklich besser.
Es macht es an vielen Stellen nur komplizierter.
Also ich persönlich verstehe den Sinn nicht davon.
Was mir einleuchtet ist, dass man jetzt die Profilbilder customisieren kann.
Ja, das finde ich gut.
Ach stimmt, wo ist denn hier?
YouTube, gucken wir hier, das ist doch excellent.
Ist das der hier?
Gehe ich mal voraus, oder?
YouTube PlayStay.
Ich gucke mal, was schreiben eigentlich die Games dazu?
Playstation.
Achso, das ist ja nicht die GameStar, die da was zu schreiben.
Das ist ja die GamePro, die da was zu schreiben.
Weil die haben es ja mit Konsole sonst nicht so.
Playstation Event, Reveal Event.
Was ist denn der offizielle Stream auf YouTube?
Hier, den da.
Das ist der Stream, den ich aufhabe.
Ja, das ist der Stream, den ich aufhabe, hier schon.
Gibt es das auch in German?
Deutsch, die Zukunft des Gaming.
Okay Leute, ihr dürft es euch aussuchen.
So, wollen wir es uns in Deutsch angucken oder in Original?
Japanisch.
Japanisch wäre auch was.
Gibt es das überhaupt auf Japanisch?
Ja, hier.
Wie heißt Playstation eigentlich auf Japanisch?
So wahrscheinlich.
Nee, wir gucken uns das auf Englisch an.
Gibt es denn da schon Prediction?
Playstation 5?
Was schreiben denn irgendwelche komischen Leute?
Ich habe von den Seiten nichts gehört.
Was?
Ach, das ist wo die Leute schreiben, was sie gerne hätten.
Also ich habe ja persönlich keine Erwartungen und keine Ahnung davon.
Weil ich die Playstation 4 zwar zur Release gekauft habe,
aber quasi 5 Stunden anhatte oder so.
Na ja, 30, 40 Stunden insgesamt vielleicht.
Dance Dance Revolution Mario, ist das denn Ihr Ernst?
Ich wusste gar nicht, dass dieses Spiel überhaupt existiert.
Future of Gaming Predictions.
Ja, Predictions.
Console Hardware.
Gut, dazu werden sie was erzählen.
Und das Ding wird nicht so aussehen.
Oder?
Nein, das wird nicht so aussehen.
Das Ding wird relativ klassisch aussehen wie bisher.
Die Xbox ist ja so ein komischer Würfel.
Horizon Zero Dawn 2, möglich.
Eigentlich ist es mir persönlich ziemlich wurscht, was die bei Sony machen.
Ich hoffe nur, dass sich die Plattform wieder lohnt.
Also ich werde es mir wahrscheinlich nicht zur Release kaufen,
aber ich werde es mir irgendwann kaufen.
Dann hoffe ich, dass es was Gescheites gibt.
30 FPS 1080p, by the way.
Man hofft ja auch, dass Call of Duty irgendwas ankündigt.
Und es gibt ja die Gerüchte,
dass das neue Call of Duty einfach nur Black Ops heißen wird,
was absolut komplett hirnverbrannt ist.
Wenn du mal überlegst, das letzte Black Ops hieß 4,
das heißt Black Ops gab es schon.
Und wenn Black Ops Release, also neues Black Ops,
was einfach nur Black Ops heißt, nicht Black Ops 1 ist,
sondern einfach nur Black Ops und nach Black Ops 4 jetzt erscheint.
Was ist mit denen los?
Ich weiß es nicht.
Playstation VR 2.
Na ja.
Freut ihr euch auf irgendwas?
Also vielleicht haben wir ja den einen oder anderen,
der viel Playstation spielt.
Ist für euch irgendwas dabei, wo ihr sagt,
oh ja, da warte ich drauf.
Ja, Battlefield verkackt es auch richtig mit der Benahmung.
Likely Call of Duty Black Ops, die Benahmung.
Ich kriege echt Anfänge.
Bloodborne Remastered, Who Cares, Resident Evil 8.
Ach, juckt mich auch nicht wirklich.
Ich habe den ersten Teil nicht mal gespielt,
also ja, warum nicht?
Killzone X.
Och nee, ein neues Killzone brauche ich nicht wirklich.
Das wäre cool.
Allerdings vielleicht mit irgendeinem besseren Namen.
Assassin's Creed juckt mich beim besten Willen gerade gar nicht.
Schauen wir mal.
World of War 2 gibt es auch schon für Playstation 2.
Jaja, die ganzen Spiele gab es alle schon mal.
Auch Black Ops gab es schon.
Total Fail im Endeffekt.
So, 88 Minuten.
Was macht man denn so lange?
Oh, oh, nee.
Oh, wird das Ganze auch auf Mixer gestreamt?
Auf Mixer gibt es keinen Playstation Channel.
Was denn da los?
Ist Mixer einfach zu unbedeutend?
Und ist Mixer zu Microsoft?
Black Mesa Let's Play.
Ich habe Black Mesa hier, glaube ich, schon zweimal im Stream durchgespielt.
Wie oft soll ich das nochmal...
Okay, nein, sorry, nicht komplett durchgespielt,
weil das eine Send-Apple ist so kacke, da hatte ich keinen Bock drauf.
Hast du auf dem Discord die Battlefield News gesehen?
Nee, Sebaro.
Kannst du mal einen Link schicken?
Also ich habe gelesen, dass ergeblich Battlefield 3 Remake schon eine Weile in der Mache ist.
Hier, guck mal, da steht es doch.
Aber ich will kein Battlefield 3 Remake.
Ich will kein Battlefield 3 Remake.
Battlefield 3 war mein Lieblings-Battlefield bei Company 2.
Aber das ist nicht...
Also erstens ist das nicht alt genug und schlecht genug vom Technik,
dass es in Remake irgendwie rechtfertigen würde.
Und außerdem, ich will ein neues, gutes Battlefield, was lange supportet wird.
Das einzige, was sein kann, ist, dass die Battlefield 3 Remastered raushauen.
Remastered?
Was willst du überhaupt am Battlefield 3 großartig remastern?
Das Game sieht sogar heute noch ziemlich gut aus.
Und ich könnte mir vorstellen, die wollen jetzt einfach die Zeit überbrücken.
Vielleicht im Battlefield auf Steam.
Die wollen die Zeit wahrscheinlich überbrücken.
Ich muss übrigens mal was trinken, weil ich habe irgendwie einen trockenen Hals.
Und wenn ich jetzt noch zwei Stunden, drei Stunden laber...
Ist das hier der Almighty, Almighty Duck, der auch schon die anderen Sachen geleakt hat?
Ja, ne, das ist der.
Geh ich mal von aus.
Der heißt plus jetzt anders.
Ja, also es wäre ein logischer Zug, dass man Battlefield 3 Remastered raushaut,
weil man muss ja irgendwie bis zum Battlefield 6 Release überbrücken.
Allerdings, ich brauche es nicht.
Battlefield 3 ist vollkommen in Ordnung.
Ja, mal schauen.
Ich meine, es wäre natürlich geil, wenn das Game dadurch ein bisschen mehr bevölkert wird,
aber im Endeffekt wollen die einfach nur die alten Fans noch mal neu abfrühstücken.
Ich meine, ich habe Battlefield 3 gekauft auf drei Plattformen.
Inklusive Battle... ne, wie hieß das?
Hieß das Battle Pass?
Ne, Battle Pass ist das in Call of Duty.
Wie hieß denn das?
Premium.
Zeig mich mal.
Und sonst was.
Also, mehr Geld für Battlefield 3 muss ich ehrlich gesagt nicht ausgeben.
Man kann Battlefield 3 heute noch spielen.
Ein bisschen vollere Server wären gut.
Aber dazu muss man eher zu Battlefield 4 gehen,
weil man quasi einen Modern Warfare Style Battlefield spielen will.
Hab ich eigentlich mein Dingsprogramm?
Ja, aufzeichnungsprogramm.
Welche Ryzen-CPU möchtest du in der Zukunft kaufen?
Ja, am liebsten einen Ryzen 4950X.
Aber den gibt es ja noch nicht.
Ja.
Den würde ich mir am liebsten kaufen, wenn es einen gäbe.
Und dazu eine 3080Ti.
Spielst du auch FIFA?
Ne.
Also das einzige, was ich aktuell spiele, ist Warzone und Path of Exile.
Ah ja.
Ob ich jetzt nicht was da heute großartig kommen könnte.
Ich hoffe mal, dass der Stream spannender wird wie der letzte.
Die letzten Playstation-Streams.
Ich kann mich an die letzten Playstation-Streams noch erinnern.
Das war zwar eine Developer-Rede,
aber selbst aus technischer Sicht fand ich es langweilig.
Und die anderen Sony-Sachen, die wir gesehen haben,
die waren echt hardcore Resident-Sleeper.
Microsoft war auch ziemlich Resident-Sleeper.
Was ich bei Microsoft immer lustig finde,
nicht dass es bei Sony großartig anders wäre,
was ich bei Microsoft immer lustig finde,
ist, vor jedem Scheiß, egal ob es Weltpremiere ist oder nicht,
haben die mittlerweile ihren Einspieler World Premiere.
Vor allem, das Game hast du vorher schon Previews und sonst was überall
in der GameStar am Endeffekt gelesen.
Also quasi jetzt nicht die Quelle, die jetzt für absolute Leaks
und Bleeding-Edge-Informationen bekannt ist.
Und dann kommt bei dem Microsoft World Premiere.
Und dann sagt man, Moment, man hat doch schon alles gesehen.
Was ist jetzt bei der schönen Weltpremiere?
Oh Gott.
Twitter schreiben.
Die Musik ist ein bisschen MonkaS.
Das ist der Endgegner aus Mario Galaxy.
Sag mal, warum kann mein iPhone Sony nicht Autocompleten?
Na gut, habe ich mir gerade beantwortet, weil es mein iPhone ist.
Warum sollte das iPhone das können?
In der Playstation ist es in Ryzen drin, klar, natürlich.
Ja, es gab schon...
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich das richtig sagen soll,
aber ich glaube, es ist eine gute Idee.
Ich glaube, es ist eine gute Idee.
Ja, es gab schon...
Ich bin mir gar nicht sicher, ob die PS5 Hardware schon komplett klar ist,
aber es ist in Ryzen drin.
Es ist eine AMD, also eine Art Ryzen,
die wahrscheinlich nicht Ryzen heißen wird,
aber im Endeffekt ist da höchstwahrscheinlich eine Ryzen drin.
Würde ich sagen, wir müssen mal kurz gucken, ob es nicht schon bestätigt ist.
Aber es ist in Ryzen drin und es ist eine AMD-Grafikkarte drin,
also quasi CPU und Grafikkarte vom gleichen Hersteller.
Es ist eine super, dolle, mega, übertrieben, krasse SSD drin.
Das weiß ich auch nur daher, weil wir uns die Präsentation davon angeguckt haben.
Und bevor ich eingeschlafen bin...
Sagen wir mal, ist das Stream gerade am Abgang?
Vodafone!
Jetzt heute nicht!
Okay, ich gehe direkt auf Twitter flame.
Also okay, okay, wir geben ihnen bis 45 Zeit. Bis 45 kriegen sie Zeit.
Okay, also Twitter. Nee, nee, nee, bis 45. Ich gehe direkt auf Twitter flameen.
Okay, also Twitter. Nee, nee, nee, bis 45. Ich gebe ihnen bis 45 Zeit. Bis 45 gebe ich ihnen Zeit.
Wechsel lieber zur Telekom, das ist auch nicht der Weisheitsteil.
Telekom ist genau so ein Scheißladen, aus anderen Gründen.
Aber zumindest ist die Technik halbwegs brauchbar im Vergleich zu Vodafone.
160p Stream. Exzellente Idee.
Die Musik passt auch richtig gut dazu, oder?
Na, geht's wieder?
Ey, ich glaube, es geht wieder.
Wechseln zu Unity Media. Exzellente Idee.
Ähm, ja, scheint wieder zu funktionieren.
Ähm, es sind alle Provider kacke.
Die Telekom ist auch kacke.
Aber auf anderer Ebene. Bei der Telekom funktioniert in der Regel wenigstens die Netzwerktechnik.
Also sprich, das Wichtigste bei einem Provider.
Noch am besten Problem ist, dass die Telekom nicht die Geschwindigkeit bei mir hat.
Und die Telekom anderweitig Spasten sind.
Zum Beispiel, weil sie mir irgendwelche Abmahnungen schicken für Anschlüsse, die überhaupt nicht mir gehören.
Das hab ich euch ja schon erzählt.
Hab ich übrigens nie wieder was von gehört, ne?
Der einzige Pro- also, äh, der Chat sagt, der einzige Provider, bei dem ich bisher noch von keiner einzigen Seelen irgendwas Positives gehört hab, ist Piyu.
Was ist das denn? Piyu?
Ist das was türkisches? Piyur.
Oder so.
Oder was isländisches könnte das sein. Piyur. Piyur.
Was ist Piyur? Piyur.
Piyur. Telekolumbus.
Telekolumbus.
Ey, das sieht aus wie Kinderkanal, nicht wie ein Provider.
Mehrere Tier 3 Provider. Ah ja.
Komm, ich guck mal.
Wo kann man einen Verfügbarkeitscheck machen von Piyur?
Oh, Verfügbarkeit prüfen.
Ach so, ja, ok, ich muss jetzt mal irgendeinen Fake eingeben.
Äh, 6 0 3 2 9, mal gucken, was die in Frankfurt haben.
Ähm, Ort, Straße, äh, keine Ahnung, Gutloidstraße 100.
Die Gutloidstraße hat mehr als vier Hausnummern.
Jetzt prüfen.
Leider noch nicht verfügbar.
Das ist ja toll, aber die Gutloidstraße hat trotzdem, glaub, 350 Hausnummern oder so.
Die Musik ist huge.
Irgendwie ist man, ist das der Rechner gerade langsam?
Zeig mal her.
Ich muss mal kurz Prozesserexplorer aufmachen und gucken, was da irgendwie so viel RAM frisst.
Oder frisst er auch fast viel RAM oder viel Auslastung?
Nö, eigentlich gar nicht, alles gut.
Exzellent.
Piyur, hab ich wirklich noch nie gehört, noch nie.
Ok, Piyur, gucken wir mal, äh, Bewertung.
Wie, von Unity Media?
Unity Media gibt's da nicht mal.
1,3 Sterne.
Das ist aber wirklich schlecht.
Fuck, Alter.
Was ist denn das?
Was macht denn Skyrim bei Best of Nintendo Music?
Ach stimmt, den Kram gibt's ja mittlerweile auch auf der Switch.
Hab ich ja ganz vergessen.
Skyrim gibt's ja nur mittlerweile echt für alles.
Ohne Kopf.
Worst Internet Provider ever.
Worst Customer Service ever.
Ok, das ist schlecht.
Das ist so ein Anbieter.
Den würde ich, da würde ich mir eigentlich fast schon einen Anschluss dafür holen.
Also einen zweiten Anschluss.
Nur, weil's lustig ist und man permanent lustigen Content erstellen könnte.
Da könnten wir im Stream, könnten wir bei Piyur anrufen und fragen, was denn los ist.
Ich könnte Videos machen, wo ich irgendwie messe, wie kaputt Piyur ist.
Einfach rein, weil's lustig ist, müsste man sich dafür schon einen Anschluss holen.
Piyur.
Ach du Schei- oh.
Berlin F.
Hahn.
Hein.
Zwar damit alles prima.
Ja noch wahrscheinlich.
Piyur.
Nee.
Also ich muss ehrlich sagen, Leute, der Chat ist wirklich wieder heute sehr, sehr big brain,
weil von dem Anbieter hab ich noch nie was gehört.
Keine Ahnung, dass der überhaupt existiert hat bis eben.
Fake.
Genau.
Fake News.
Ah ja, genau.
Wir waren ja bei den Hardware Specs von der PS5.
Full PS5 Specification.
Aber so wirklich eine ordentliche Übersicht ist das nicht.
Äh, ziemlicher Mist.
Stimmt das, was hier steht?
Ich kann mich da nämlich überhaupt noch mal dran erinnern.
Waren das ein 8-Kern oder ein 12-Kern?
Ich glaube 8 Kerne stimmt.
War es nicht so, dass man 12 Kerne vermutet hat und es sind am Ende jetzt doch nur 8 gewesen?
Ich glaube schon.
Zumindest sind Xbox und PS5 wieder ziemlich gleich auf, was Leistung angeht.
Sony macht hier richtig große Attacke mit ihrer SSD.
Microsoft hat ein paar andere Sachen, aber unterm Strich macht es da keinen großen Unterschied.
Die Xbox ist ein bisschen schneller, aber im Großen und Ganzen dürfte es für die Games jetzt nicht so viel ausmachen.
8 x Zen 2 gleich 16.
Ah, jetzt verstehe ich es.
Excellent, Big Brain.
So sieht es aus.
How much FPS will PS5...
Ist klar, das weiß Google natürlich.
Ja, ist klar.
Ich kann auch einen dreifarbigen Bildschirm in 4K und 120 FPS anzeigen lassen.
Das ist kein Problem.
Dass es Spiele in 4K und 120 FPS auf der PS5 gibt, ist eher im Land eher anzusiedeln, als dass das wirklich der Fall sein wird.
Wir können uns freuen, wenn die meisten Games jetzt endgültig mal durchgängig 1080p 60 FPS sind.
Ja, CSGO, aber CSGO werden sie wohl nicht nochmal releasen für die PS5.
Gab es ja mal für die Xbox und die PS4, glaubst du gar.
War das noch 360?
Ich weiß es gar nicht mehr.
Aber das war total sinnlos.
Soll ich mal in der Chat gucken, falls ich was vergessen habe zu beantworten?
Die Xbox sagt 8K.
Okay.
Ja, es ist ja ein Unterschied zwischen, was rein der Output, also was die Hardware-Spezifikationen der Display-Schnittstelle hergeben und was Spiele im Endeffekt wirklich rendern, sind ja komplett zwei Paar Schuhe.
Schau dir mal Salt-Fiber an.
Salt-Fiber klingt irgendwie schon ziemlich nach Flame.
Salt-Fiber.
Bewertung.
Wenn es denn mal läuft, dann richtig gut.
Oh, der hat auch exzellente Sterne, 1,3.
Salt-Mobile.
Oh, Moment, warum kann ich hier meinen E-Modes schreiben?
Auswandern, Schweiz.
Hatte ich jetzt eigentlich nicht vor.
Aber wenn die Leute hier weiter so am Rad drehen, dann mache ich es vielleicht irgendwann mal.
Die spinnen ja alle richtig rum aktuell.
Ja, aber zur Frage, was ich mir gerne für Hardware kaufen würde.
Tatsächlich, am liebsten würde ich mir den Ryzen 4950X kaufen, wenn der das verspricht, was man jetzt erahnen kann, ohne 3080Ti.
Aber das dauert wohl noch mindestens bis Ende des Jahres.
Spektrum 8.
Oh, der Michael in 50 Milliarden morgen in einem Vorstellungsgespräch.
Bei was, wie heißen die?
Spektrum 8.
Welche Seite, die da?
Okay, können wir uns angucken.
Aber gib nicht so viel drauf, was ich erzähle.
Im Endeffekt muss es ja zu dir passen, ja.
Also, Spektrum.
Die werden schon mal niemals fertig hier.
Wie lange das Event geht?
Naja, wenn man sich die letzten Sony Events anguckt, dann eine Stunde oder eineinhalb Stunden.
Unlimited.
Als was bewirbst du dich denn da?
Weil, Jobs.
Das Webdesign ist schon mal nicht, ja, ach komm, geht doch, geht doch.
Also unsere Benefits, okay, also schauen wir uns das mal an, unsere Benefits.
Vertrauenszeit, okay, das gibt es mittlerweile bei vielen.
Meinen die Kleidzeit oder meinen die Vertrauenszeit?
Vertrauenszeit würde heißen, es wird nichts erfasst, aber es muss ja was erfasst werden.
Getränke, das ist gut.
Obst.
Oder wie der Schwabe sagt, Obst.
Ist auch nett, ja, warum nicht?
Heißt Benefits nicht Vorteil, ja, ja, ja.
Ruhebereich.
Das haben wir übrigens auch.
Hab ich euch glaube ich noch nicht erzählt, wir haben in der Firma auch einen Ruhebereich.
Da geht nie jemand hin.
Hauptsächlich wahrscheinlich, weil du ausstechen musst.
Aber der ist gar nicht schlecht.
Das ist ein Ruhebereich, der hat komplett grüne Sofas.
Und es stehen links und rechts zwei Surface Hubs.
Surface Hubs, wo Kaminfeuer drauf läuft.
Also man hätte jetzt ja auch wirklich echte Pflanzen hinstellen können, aber das war nicht genug.
Man lieber grüne Sofas und nen Surface Hub mit Kaminfeuer hingestellt.
Altersvorsorge, das ist schon mal nicht schlecht.
Wenn man da länger bleiben will, ist eine betriebliche Altersvorsorge nicht verkehrt.
Aber halt immer nur unter der Voraussetzung, dass eben der Arbeitgeber die Hälfte bezahlt.
Dann lohnt sich das.
Homeoffice, ungünstige Termine.
Das ist auch schon mal gut, dass ihr das hinschreibt.
Firmenwagen.
Okay, wenn man braucht, warum nicht?
Unfallversicherung.
Gute Verkehrsanbietung.
Das ist tatsächlich ein Benefit, aber da können die ja wenig für.
Surface Hub für Kaminfeuer, habt ihr zu viel Geld? Ja, wir haben viel zu viel Geld.
Ganzen Bankversicherungsläden haben zu viel Geld.
Surface, diese, da, Surface, Surface Hub, diese Dinger hier.
Ähm, ne, ne, ne, ne.
Ja, die da.
Die Teile, da haben wir jede Menge von.
Das juckt aber, das juckt die Firma, wo ich arbeite, nicht, dass es 10k kostet.
Das ist denen vollkommen egal.
Was geht noch weiter? Spielzeug?
Datscheibe, Kicker und Bilder.
Okay, das braucht kein Mensch.
Man geht ja auf die Arbeit, um zu arbeiten.
Und um pünktlich heimzugehen, wenn man seine Arbeit erledigt hat.
Hunde geduldet.
Okay, das wird mir persönlich auf den Keks gehen.
Aber es ist Geschmackssache.
Das wäre gut noch schlecht jetzt.
Ähm.
Bei uns muss niemand ungewollt schwitzen.
Klimaanlage.
Da hast du dann die Mädels, die sagen, oh nein, mir ist es zu kalt.
Da hast du ja andere, die sagen, oh ne, mir ist es jetzt zu warm.
Aber Klimaanlage ist schon, Klimaanlage ist ja sogar bei manchen Sachen Pflicht, wenn es da zu warm wird.
Und Wuffi lieb ist.
Okay, ähm.
Michael, hab ich dich gefragt, als was du dich da bewirbst?
Anwendungsentwickler, ah, okay.
Chef-OP sag ich, denk ich mir auch.
Wer braucht Spielzeug?
Ich geh einfach lieber heim, wenn meine Arbeitszeit vorbei ist.
Oder Stunde rum sitzt und was spielt.
Spiel grad ja auch daheim, dann kann ich spielen, was ich will.
Letztens hab ich ein Video auf YouTube gesehen von irgendeiner Firma, die angepriesen hat.
Oder ein Video, was das Video gezeigt hat, so rum.
Von irgendeiner Firma, die gesagt haben, wir hatten einen Mario, wie sie haben einen Mario Kart Raum.
Da dachte ich mir aus, alter, was brauch ich einen Mario Kart Raum auf der Arbeit?
Will meine Arbeit machen, dann geh ich heim, gut ist.
Umfeld.
Der Arbeitsplatz sieht schon mal ganz gut aus hier.
Drei ordentliche Bildschirme.
Ein bisschen zu offen, aber ich weiß nicht, was das für ein Laden ist.
Aber Arbeitsplatzausstattung sieht schon mal ganz gut aus.
Warum sind die Bilder eigentlich so furzklein?
Und was, was macht denn der Laden?
Was macht denn der Laden überhaupt?
Was machen die denn?
Was machen die?
About.
Neue Projekte, hoffentlich mal ist es kein Webdesign.
Okay, ich hab keine Ahnung, das ist absolut nichts sagend.
Webshops, okay, also mit Webdesign haben sie es wirklich beim besten Willen nicht so, ne?
Ich mein, wer hat dieses Menüdesign, das ist ja absolut Zumutung.
Das ist Nekrodancer oder sowas, ne?
Musik.
Ja, genau.
Crypt of Nekrodancer.
Oh, ist da Anzug Pflicht?
Michael, wer weiß.
Also mit Webdesign haben sie es auf jeden Fall schon mal nicht.
Mach mal Darkreader aus.
Oh, dann wäre ich aber so gepletten.
Übrigens, ich hab nichts gesagt, den Darkreader muss ich echt ausmachen.
Also die können dafür gar nichts.
Wie sieht das Menü jetzt aus?
Okay, das Menü ist auch nicht besser.
Oh, Moment.
Na ja, viel besser ist das Menü ehrlich gesagt auch nicht.
Michael, du hattest zur Schule Anzug an, willst du mich debaten?
Warum?
Okay, aber mit Webdesign haben sie es trotzdem nicht so.
Mitarbeiter-Events, oje, MonkaS.
Ein mit unordentliche Hose ist ja, ist da, das ist ja was anderes.
Aber komplett im Anzug würde ich nicht in die Schule gehen.
Aber jeder wieder macht, ja.
Neben der Weihnachtsfeier und dem Sommerfest haben wir auch noch diverse Teamabende, oje, oje.
Da würde ich gleich sagen, habe ich keinen Bock drauf.
Aber Michael, wenn das was für dich ist, was dir gefällt, ey, da habe ich nichts gesagt, ja.
Ein erster Abend mit uns wird bereits in der Bewerbungsphase stattfinden.
Oh nein, oh Gott, oh, hör auf.
Du musst an dem Kram teilnehmen und gut wetter machen, dass sie dich überhaupt einstellen oder was?
Oh, nee.
Da hätte ich, da hätte ich keinen Bock drauf.
Ey, aber manchmal, ja, manchmal kann, das muss jetzt nicht, du wirst nie was finden, wo 100%ig alles gut ist.
Genauso wenig, wie es kaum was gibt, wo 100%ig alles schlecht ist.
Vielleicht ist das auch so eine Sache, wo du einfach Augen zu und durch musst.
Oder du kannst sehen, wenn es eine wirklich gute Firma ist und man denen sagt, man hat Probleme mit, ähm, quasi Ansammlung von vielen Menschen,
dass das nichts mit den Leuten zu tun hat, dass du die irgendwie, ähm, dass du irgendwie die Leute abwerten willst oder so, ne.
Sondern du hast Probleme mit Anzahl, mit Events, wo viele Leute sind.
Dann sollte das eine gute Firma verstehen.
Ähm, Martin sehe ich genauso.
Exakt meine Aussage, ich will da arbeiten, ich muss mit denen nicht unbedingt befreundet sein.
Ich muss noch nicht mal wirklich gut finden, was ein Laden macht.
Es hat seine Vorteile, aber muss nicht sein.
Ähm, im Endeffekt müssen, sollen sich einfach nur beide Seiten an den Arbeitsvertrag halten.
Also sprich, ich geh dahin, erbringe meine Leistung, dafür wünsche ich meine Kohle.
Und das war's.
Bei uns ist demnächst auch wieder, äh, Sommerfest.
Und bei uns haben sie, jetzt können sie ja wegen Corona kein Sommerfest machen.
Unser Sommerfest ist jetzt rein online.
Per Livestream.
Dort, wo ich arbeite.
Da kannst du mit Zoom, per Zoom, Alter.
Die haben einen leitenden offiziellen Livestream, da ist unser Netzwerkteam voll in Panik.
Weil so viel Traffic und so.
Ähm, und man kann, das wird moderiert, das ist, glaub ich, zweieinhalb Stunden Livestream oder so.
Und dabei gibt's da Gewinnspiele, wo man mit Zoom teilnehmen kann und sowas.
Ich werd das mal fünf Minuten einschalten zum Cringen und dann bin ich wieder weg.
Vielleicht auch gar nicht, je nachdem.
Eiskäuter war bei mir auch so.
Der einzige Grund, warum ich früher zu Weihnachtsfeiern hin bin.
Zu Weihnachtsfeiern hin bin ist, weil es kostenloses Essen gab.
Ja.
Und noch einen anderen Grund, den ich euch noch nie erzählt hab, wo ich's voll verkackt hab.
Es gab, weiß ich noch, beim Provider, als kann ich jetzt ja erzählen.
Das kann ja eh keiner genau zuordnen.
Wo ich noch bei dem Provider gearbeitet hab, wo ich meine Ausbildung gemacht hab.
Oh Siebaro, hab ich das doch erzählt.
Dort, wo ich meine Ausbildung gemacht hab, da gab's auch eine mit Auszubildende.
Und in die war ich so ein bisschen verknallt.
Und das war auch einer der Gründe, warum ich immer auf die Weihnachtsfeier gefahren bin.
Das war so das einzige Mal im Jahr, wo man, oder einer weniger Mal im Jahr, wo man die gesehen hat.
Und dann war's halt auch nicht so wirklich in der Firma, wo man den ganzen Tag arbeiten muss.
Und jetzt passt mal auf, der Max hat's extrem, extrem verschissen.
An der einen Weihnachtsfeier, das dürfte sogar wahrscheinlich die letzte Weihnachtsfeier gewesen sein,
bevor wir fertig waren mit der Ausbildung.
Also da saß die auch bei mir am Tisch und da sind irgendwie gerade mal kurzzeitig alle weg gewesen.
Und da hat die zu mir gesagt, ja sie wird jetzt gerne heimgehen, ob ich sie nicht noch quasi zum Bahnhof bringen kann.
Und ich hab's nicht gecheckt.
Ich hab's nicht gecheckt.
Ich hab nicht nein gesagt.
Ich hab gesagt, ja klar.
Dann sind wir losgegangen und irgendwie haben das dann auch ein paar andere mitgekriegt,
dass wir aufgebrochen sind.
Also irgendwie zwei, drei andere Leute, auch noch ein paar andere Mädels da von der Firma.
Und die haben gesagt, ach sie müssen auch zum Bahnhof, sie gehen mit ihr zum Bahnhof.
Also insofern, ich muss nicht mit, so nach dem Motto.
Also da, ja gut, dann ist gut, dann geh ich gleich, dann mach ich mich vom Acker.
Das war richtig bescheuert.
Ich hab's nicht gecheckt, Leute.
Ich war zu blöd für.
Ich war zu doof für.
Ja, Pains Jam.
Richtig Pains Jam.
Das hab ich nicht schnell genug.
Dabei war die Sache eigentlich, nee ich war gar nicht mal so besoffen.
Ich war einfach doof.
Ich hab's nicht gecheckt.
Doch eigentlich hab ich's gecheckt.
Ja.
Aber so Sachen hat wahrscheinlich jeder was, ja.
Ich hätte sagen müssen, ja klar, ich komm noch mit zum Bahnhof.
Und wenn die anderen dann weg gewesen wären,
dann hätte sich bestimmt irgendwas ergeben, so nach dem Motto, ja hier der Zug dauert noch eine Weile.
Oder so nach dem Motto, ja ist ja noch, ist ja eigentlich noch früh, ist ja noch Zeit oder irgendwas, ja.
Ich hab's verkackt.
Keine Nerven gehabt, vielleicht auch das, ja.
Aber einfach nicht gecheckt.
Das ist so eine Sache, die ärgert mich heute noch, dass ich nicht gecheckt hab.
Weil es beruhte irgendwie auf Gegenseitigkeit, ja.
Also ich hatte schon den Eindruck, dass nicht nur ich die ganz gut find, sondern umgedreht auch.
Also das hätte, das hätte was werden können, ja.
Und außerdem genau Krypto Meister, ansonsten hätte sie nicht gefragt,
warum sollte die irgendwie so einen random Dude aus Frankfurt fragen,
wenn man in einer anderen Stadt dann da zum Bahnhof gebracht hat und so dalbe knackt, ja.
Ah ja.
Tja, ja Michael.
Sieht doch eigentlich ganz okay aus.
Bis auf die Team Events.
Fachinformatik anwesend, dafür bewirbst du dich glaube ich, ja.
Wann kommt denn die Mist des Wubblors?
Wenn ich mich, wenn ich weiter meine bisherige Linie,
was zwischenmenschliche Interaktionen angeht und zwischenmenschliche Beziehungen verfolge
oder besser gesagt die nicht vorhandene, dann wird das wahrscheinlich nie was.
Geh einfach wieder auf Firmevents, ich hasse Firmevents.
Was, Prämie habe ich nicht gelesen, wo steht was von Prämie?
Leistungsprämie, bei uns gibt es keine Leistungsprämie,
aber dafür investieren wir das Budget in ein mehrtägiges externes Team.
Okay, hätten sie lieber gar nichts schreiben sollen.
Wie viele Firmevents machen die eigentlich, Mitarbeiter Events und Leistungsprämie Firmen Events?
Hör ja gar nicht auf.
Der Chat ist gerade beschäftigt jetzt, sich gegenseitig zu erzählen, wie sehr sie schon verkackt haben.
Also das ist die Ausbildung wahrscheinlich, wo du dich beworben hast, denke ich mal.
Okay, das grüne auf dem blau sieht nicht wirklich gut aus.
Fließende Sprachkenntnisse in Deutsch.
Fachhochschulreif und höher, zuverlässig oder was?
Okay, bla bla bla bla.
Blitzbewerbung.
Okay.
Bewerben wir uns mal.
PAP-Kenntnisse.
CSS, JavaScript.
Hast du vielleicht schon erfahren, das verwendet man noch?
Cent-Framework, das hat man vor 1000 Jahren verwendet in der Webentwicklung.
Vue.js, Laravel, ja das ist was, damit kann man was anfangen, aber Cent?
Ich weiß, was wir hochladen, wartet mal.
Andere Sachen, die du gut beherrschst.
Face-Rollen.
Was?
Aha, exzellent.
Okay, alles klar.
Warum nicht?
C++-Flame, ja.
Was?
Michael, die wissen doch nicht, dass du das bist, Alter.
Das hat doch damit nichts zu tun.
Bei denen kannst du, die machen echt einen guten Eindruck, bis auf die Team-Events.
Team-Events suckt.
Ein Pui wurde direkt weitergeleitet, ja.
Nein Michael, das glaube ich nicht, dass die meinen Stream gucken.
Und wenn nicht, überleg dir mal.
Stell dir vor, die gucken wirklich meinen Stream und es fällt auf dich zurück.
Dann ist das doch eher von Vorteil für dich, da habt ihr gemeinsames Gesprächsthema.
Da kannst du sagen, wie ihr guckt das auch.
Da kannst du sagen, Alter, was für ein Spaß.
Da hast du, eigentlich ist es sogar gut, wenn die meinen Stream gucken.
So, was?
Hi, habe mir den Mikrotik, was?
Routerboard plus 5, die Mikrotik-Bezeichnung, Alter.
Könntest du mal einen Mikrotik-Guide machen?
Nicht wirklich.
Das ist ein äußerst komplexes Thema, Router OS.
Aber der Router ist echt gut, der ist wirklich richtig gut.
Wenn du halt das brauchst, was der kann.
Also ein Fritzbox-Ersatz ist es nicht.
Warum ist auf Mikrotik mein?
Ein Adblock aus.
Also ein richtiger Fritzbox-Ersatz ist es nicht.
Dafür ist es ein deutlich besserer Router mit deutlich besserem Betriebssystem für
und Funktionen, was Routing angeht, wie die Fritzbox.
Ja, der Name ist vielleicht ein bisschen MonkaS.
RB4011.
Aber es ist so, die Sachen haben bei Mikrotik eine gewisse Logik.
Das ist Routerboard.
Moment, ich hab meinen Chat irgendwie verschoben.
Routerboard 400i.
1 SFP plus Port.
11 Gigabit Ports, wahrscheinlich vermute ich mal.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10.
Ok, was auch immer.
11 Ports.
Also in dem Fall ergibt die Mikrotikbenahmung auch nicht so wirklich Sinn, oder?
Oder sind es 5 SFP?
Ne.
Ok.
Die Mikrotikbenahmung gibt ja nicht wirklich Sinn.
Dass es einen Axis-Point hat?
Und was für einen Axis-Point?
Ok, die Mikrotikbenahmung gibt meistens Sinn, aber in dem Fall check ich sie zumindest nicht.
Aber der Router ist wirklich gut.
Hinten ist noch eine Konsole.
Vielleicht ist es der, ja.
Wofür hast du den denn gekauft?
Wenn ich jetzt finde, wer das gefragt hat.
Hat der auch einen DSL-Modem?
Ne.
Unter anderem hat er auch keinen DSL-Modem.
Er hat keine Deckbasis-Station.
Also einen Fritzbox-Ersatz ist es wie gesagt nicht.
Was für eine Route hast du?
Ich habe einen Hex-POE.
Und eine Unity-Media-Connect-Box und noch eine Fritzbox.
Ähm, das ist eine gute Frage hier.
Hast du schon mal...
Wobei wir können uns die Fragen auch hier angucken.
Dann seht ihr wenigstens welche, welche ich nehme.
Schul, also.
Hast du schon mal Schulprojekte aufgeschoben?
Und wenn ja, wie ging es aus?
Ich schiebe fast alle Projekte, die ich habe auf.
Weil ich total faul bin.
Ich schiebe fast alle auf.
Und wie ging es aus?
Meistens ohne Probleme.
Also es ist bei mir auch so.
Auch wenn ich auf der Arbeit irgendwas vorstellen soll.
Ich schiebe alles irgendwie auf.
Aber meistens geht es ganz gut aus.
Weil ich dann irgendwann, so kurz bevor es wirklich ernst wird,
das spüre und mich damit beschäftige.
Und mich dann aber auch auf nichts anderes mehr konzentriere.
Also zum Beispiel, wir mussten vor zwei Wochen
mal wieder eine Sache von uns vorstellen.
Und wir haben am Montagmorgen die Vorbereitung
für die Präsentation gemacht für Montag 13 Uhr.
Hat wunderbar funktioniert.
Dafür haben wir auch zwei Stunden nichts anderes gemacht.
Bei anderen Sachen muss man natürlich ein bisschen früher anfangen.
Und ich kann euch auch nur empfehlen,
wenn ihr irgendwelche Sachen vorstellen müsst,
übt das vorher mal ein paar Mal.
Es gibt zwar Naturtalente, die gut reden können.
Aber gut reden können ist bei einem Vortrag,
wo es um technische Sachen geht, auch nicht komplett alles.
Also man muss schon Ahnung haben, wovon man redet.
Und damit man sich die Sachen besser merken kann,
ist es schon sinnvoll, den Vortrag 203 Mal runterzuspulen vorher.
Vielleicht auch mit ein, zwei Zuhörern.
Aber Leute, mit denen man gut klarkommt.
Dann ist es nämlich einfacher.
Und dann kann man sich nämlich den Text viel besser merken.
Der Garten.
Der Garten sieht immer noch ziemlich genauso aus wie damals.
Bei der letzten Präsentation war eigentlich eh voll verkehrte Welt.
Wir haben so gut wie nichts Neues gemacht.
Das Einzige, was wir vorgestellt haben ist,
zusätzlich zu dem, was wir vorher vorgestellt haben,
dass wir was programmiert haben,
was Confluence abgleicht mit Server-Informationen aus einer Datenbank.
Und das haben wir vorgestellt, da waren sie alle voll begeistert.
Und da haben wir uns so gefragt,
was machen sie erst mal, wenn wir wirklich was gemacht haben.
Musstest du mal einen Vortrag in Englisch halten?
Ja.
Das war eher...
Das war eher so.
Ups.
Ja, kann man...
Wie sagt man heutzutage?
Fühle ich total.
Nee, genau so würde ich das auch machen.
Genau so würde ich das auch machen.
Ich lasse die Sachen immer übelst lange schleifen.
Und wenn ich dann so ein inneres Gefühl bekomme,
oh, jetzt wird es aber langsam ernst, dann mache ich nichts anderes mehr.
Was soll beim PS5-Event gezeigt werden?
Das ist noch nicht so ganz klar.
Aber hoffentlich weitere Details zur PS5
und vor allem was für Games kommen.
Könntest du noch mal deine Kameras Webcams zeigen,
die du benutzt mit Custom-Filmware?
Ja.
Eine ist mir jetzt aber verreckt.
Eine ist mir komplett verreckt.
Da ist die SD-Karte...
Der SD-Kartenleser kaputtgegangen.
Die hier.
Und...
Oh, die sind viel zu teuer geworden. Warum sind die so teuer?
Davor hat die kleine...
Die kleine... Ach, das ist ein Zweierpack.
Okay.
Dann ist was anderes.
Also, ich habe 5 davon bestellt.
5 davon bestellt.
Und aktuell in Benutzung habe ich
eine im Hof.
Eine im Flur.
Eine im Keller.
Ich muss mal kurz auf meine Kameras gucken,
dass ich nichts vergesse.
Eine in dem Zimmer, wo sich die Katze immer ablegt.
Und...
Noch eine...
Am Hof-Tor.
Wobei das am Hof-Tor eine Raspberry-Pie-Kamera ist.
So.
Das lohnt sich aber nicht wirklich.
Das lohnt sich nur, wenn man sich
eine ordentliche Menge bestellt.
Weil man bezahlt bei Amazon.com,
wenn man diesen Versand nach Deutschland machen lässt.
Also sprich, die haben ja mittlerweile
eine richtig gute Möglichkeit,
Sachen nach Deutschland zu verschicken,
was auch viel schneller geht.
Die verschicken das meiste gar nicht wirklich
von Amazon.com, sondern irgendwo von hier.
Das kostet aber
25 Euro Versand zusätzlich.
Das lohnt sich also nur, wenn man da ordentlich
was kauft.
Und die Custom-Firma ist die hier.
Äh...
Alter, die Musik, was los?
Das...
Jetzt übertreiben ist es aber.
Das ist die
Custom-Firma dafür.
Das können wir auf eine MicroSD-Karte machen.
Also preisleistungsmäßig ist es okay.
Wie gesagt, 20 Dollar, 20,
25 Dollar für eine Kamera,
die von den Funktionen her echt top ist.
Mit der Custom-Firma gibt es nichts zu sagen.
Es gibt aber bessere Sachen, die man sich kaufen kann,
wenn man wirklich eine funktionsfähige,
belastbare,
ausfallssichere Kamera haben will.
Möchtest du mein Heimnetzwerk sicher machen?
Gut, das kannst du
mit dem Mikrotik-Router
schon machen.
Aber irgendwelche Advanced-Security-
Features kann der nicht.
Der hat halt eine ganz normale IP-Firewall drin.
Aber irgendwelche Inspection
oder
Proxies,
die irgendwelche Protokolle verstehen
und On-the-Fly-Viren erkennen können.
Sowas hat der nicht.
Der Mikrotik-Router hat ein ganz stinknormales,
ganz stinknormale IP-Firewall.
Dafür kann er im Gegensatz zur Fritz-Box
halt alles andere, was gute Router können.
Oder auch was gute Switches können.
Zum Beispiel in VLANs.
Und auch ziemlich schnell
intern routen.
Cheat95,
das funktioniert folgendermaßen.
Man flasht einen Bootloader.
Einen neuen Bootloader.
Und der bootet
von der SD-Karte,
wenn eine SD-Karte drin ist.
Wenn keine SD-Karte drin ist,
bootet er die Stock-Firmware
vor dem Hersteller.
Also das heißt, man kann
die Kamera immer verwenden, wie man will.
Kennst du eine gute Alternative
zu WLAN oder DLAN?
Ja, Kabel.
Was ist hier los gerade?
Unser Router ist ein Stockwerk tiefer
und wir haben eine fette
Stahlbeton. Oh, das ist schlecht.
Ähm...
Es gibt noch die Option,
wenn es...
Du kannst Richtung...
Also WLAN kannst du
mit so ein bisschen den passenden...
Wie heißt denn das?
Mit den passenden Antennen, die besonders gut
in eine Richtung abstrahlen,
kannst du es mal probieren.
DLAN ist jetzt nicht so mein Fall.
Ansonsten...
Ja, bohren.
Das ist aber auch
schwierig, ja.
Hast du vielleicht was
anderes da liegen?
Hast du vielleicht noch alte Kupferkabel
oder irgendwas von einem Telefonanschluss
da liegen? Dann kann man was machen.
Also wenn du paar Kabel hast,
mindestens zwei. Wenn du noch mindestens
zwei Kabel hast,
die dazwischen liegen, gibt es Alternativen, ja.
Äh, die Leute auf GitHub
sind auch immer dreister.
Ok, das ist ein Build, das muss ich...
Kann ich nicht im Stream aufbauen, da muss ich erstmal vorher gucken,
was das ist.
Hä? Verstehe ich nicht.
Ach, die schreiben dich an, weil du
ein Repo gestarrt hast. Ja, das ist
natürlich bescheuert.
Die sollen immer die...
einem auf den Sack gehen.
Huge-Emote-Einblendung,
ah ja, da werden wir uns wieder auslassen gleich.
Aber wie gesagt, hat kein DSL-Modem.
Hatten wir schon, hatten wir schon.
Was hindert dich jetzt daran, dich einfach nochmal
bei ihr zu melden? Ich wüsste noch nicht mal wo.
Mal ganz davon abgesehen,
das ist über zehn Jahre her.
Wahrscheinlich ist die mittlerweile alt
und hässlich, so wie ich.
Wie war dein Fazit zu Bitborn gestern?
Konnte leider irgendwann nicht mehr weiter gucken.
Ich fand's ganz gut.
Bullshit-Bingo, ich hab keinen Bullshit-Bingo dafür.
Und ich kann auch keins erstellen, weil ich absolut keine Ahnung habe,
was die ankündigen werden.
Wie war dein Fazit?
Ja, genau, also ich fand's gut.
Ich werde es nicht verwenden,
aber für jemand, der gerade auch die ganze
Smartphone-App-Geschichte braucht
und die als Autocomplete auf Android
und was man einfach
zünden kann, ist das echt nicht verkehrt.
Zur Sicherheit kann ich halt gar nichts sagen.
Hab ich mich nicht mit beschäftigt.
Das ist auch unter anderem der Grund, warum ich nach wie vor KeyPass verwende.
Weil ich KeyPass einfach traue, dass es funktioniert.
Geh auf Tinder und installier Tinder und geh auf ein paar Events.
Alles klar.
Tinder ist, glaube ich, eines der letzten Sachen, die ich mir installiere.
Und auf Events zu irgendwelchen Leuten gehen erst recht nicht.
Die sagen, save, dass es die beste Playstation ist, die jemals gemacht wurde.
Ja, das stimmt.
Kannst du bei uns anfangen?
Ich habe die Seite nicht angeguckt, weil ich was suche,
sondern weil mich jemand aus dem Chat gefragt hat,
weil ich dazu sage.
Aber ich guck's mir auch mal an. Was ist das?
Riegel Laser Measurement Systems.
Die Webseite ist optimiert für den Microsoft Internet Explorer oder so.
Aber eigentlich mag ich so Webseiten prinzipiell, die leichtgewichtig sind.
Man muss ja nicht heutzutage alles mit JavaScript machen,
nur weil es mit JavaScript geht.
Also, was wollten ihr haben?
Programmierung in JavaScript und PHP.
Mac, PC, Mac, Smartphone, Software, Dokument.
Excellent.
Wenigstens eine Sache, mit der ich mich auskenne.
Also, Software Dokumentation ist ja einfach.
Software Dokumentation kann jeder, der gut programmieren kann.
Man muss einfach so programmieren, dass es jeder versteht.
Und dann braucht man keine Dokumentation.
Da sind wir uns ja alle einig, oder?
Ja.
Und wenn man das Ganze dann noch eingecheckt hat in ordentliche Versionsverwaltung,
dann ist das quasi besser als jede Dokumentation.
Software Support.
Okay, Abschluss.
HTL Abschluss.
Was ist denn HTL?
Hohe Technische Lernabschluss.
Nee.
HTL.
Ich weiß nicht, was das ist.
Sehr gute Programmierkenntnisse.
JavaScript, PHP.
Okay, JavaScript meinetwegen, PHP geht so.
JQuery.
Okay.
Jason, Leaflet.
Ah, Leaflet.
Hey, die zwei Sachen kann ich wirklich.
Weil, wie gesagt, ich hab doch mit meinem einen Kollegen da dieses...
Die Web-Anwendung gebastelt, wo man sich Routen berechnen lassen kann.
Das ist mit Leaflet und Google Maps APIs.
Irgendwas aus Österreich.
Höhere technische Lehranstalt.
Okay.
Erfahrung in der GUI-Umsetzung.
Erfahrung, Entwicklung, Node-Anwendung.
3D-Visualisierung.
Ach, du Scheiß.
Dass das ein Web-Entwickler auch um GL und Shader gedönst kann.
Also, das ist, glaube ich, nicht so verbreitet.
Erfahrung im Umgang mit Softwareverwaltungssystemen.
Gibt ja wenigstens eine Sache, von der ich richtig Ahnung habe.
Das ist ein Stellangebot, würde ich sagen.
Lernbereitschaft.
Da könnte ich auf Österreich auswandern, das wäre doch auch nicht schlecht.
Aber ich weiß nicht, ob es da besser ist.
Ich glaube, die haben genauso viel gestörte Leute wie wir.
Das einzige deutschsprachige Land, wo ich glaube, die haben nicht so viel gestörte Leute, ist die Schweiz.
Aber das kann täuschen, weil ich noch nie in der Schweiz war.
Ach so, das Geld habe ich jetzt gar nicht nachgeguckt.
Wie viel gibt es denn?
Delphi?
Monkeys?
Wow!
Das ist aber nicht viel.
Nee, das ist aber nicht viel.
Ich meine, das sind...
Mal 12, ich weiß nicht, wie viel Monatsgeld das...
Was?
Also ganz ehrlich Leute, das kann doch nicht euer Ernst sein.
Und selbst mal 14 ist es nicht viel.
Mein WTF?
Also für 30k, da kannst du ja bei der hessischen Polizei anfangen und kriegst mehr Geld.
Wie viel verdient man mit Hartz IV so?
Nee, die meinen tatsächlich...
Also sprich, davon musst du noch Steuern bezahlen.
Gut, ich weiß nicht, wie es mit Steuern in Österreich aussieht.
Also wenn Österreich keine Steuern hat, dann mag das gehen.
Aber wenn Österreich wahrscheinlich auch recht hohe Steuern hat, dann...
Ja.
Also so eine 2-3 Tage Woche, wenn man plus ein Land mit wenig Steuern, dann wird das ja irgendwie noch durchgehen.
Aber ansonsten ist wirklich sehr wenig.
Ja.
Micharo sagt, wir haben Steuern bis zum Umfallen, aber wahrscheinlich nicht so viel wie wir.
Naja, Michael 50.000, wenn du ausgelernt hast und ein bisschen Erfahrung hast.
Komm, es kommt auf die Region an.
Kommt auf die Region an, aber...
Sag mal, in Frankfurt, in Frankfurt, wir reden erstmal nur von Frankfurt, ja?
In Frankfurt würde ich auch nach der Ausbildung nicht unter 40.000 im Jahr anfangen.
Vorausgesetzt, du kannst ein bisschen was.
Also wenn du eine fachinformatische Ausbildung gemacht hast, würde ich nicht unter 40.000 anfangen in Frankfurt.
Jetzt einfach so mal aus dem Bauch raus gesagt, ich bin da nicht der beste Quelle für, weil wie gesagt,
ich war bisher in 15 Jahren bei zwei Arbeitgebern in dem Beruf.
Also da habe ich jetzt nicht so viele Erfahrungen.
Deswegen ist es wichtig, Leute, dass man was kann.
Wenn man was kann, was die Leute haben wollen, wenn man nicht die Sachen kann,
die der 0-15-Typ kann und die einfach sind, dann ist das, dann geht das auch.
Wenn ihr natürlich nur Druckerpatronen wechseln könnt, übertrieben gesagt,
dann gibt es halt 30.000 andere, die das können.
Oder ein bisschen Windows, Windows-AD rumklicken, das kann auch jeder.
Kennt ihr euch in irgendeinem Cloud-Bereich ganz gut aus oder irgendwelche Linux-Hosting-Geschichten
oder Programmiersprachen, sonst was, was gerade angesagt ist.
Kubernetes-Sachen auch, die gerade angesagt sind.
Wenn man sich mit irgendwas auskennt, was nicht jeder da hergelaufene Feld,
Wald und Wiesen-Physikern und davon dann auch noch ein bisschen Ahnung hat,
dass man damit was anfangen kann, dann kann man auch ordentlich Kohle kriegen.
Gut, CCNA ist so was, was fast jeder hat.
Martin, CCNA haben wirklich viele.
Natürlich gibt es mehr, die es nicht haben, als die, die es haben,
aber im Umfeld, wo es zählen könnte, also sprich irgendwo bei Netzwerk-Technik-Sachen,
da wird entweder CCNA belächelt oder eins juckt keinen, das man ihnen hat.
CCNA ist die Einsteiger-Cisco-Zertifizierung.
Heißt, glaube ich, Cisco...
Warte mal, Cisco Network Associate?
Was heißt denn CCNA?
Cisco Certified Network Associate.
Ah ja, exzellent.
Das habe ich auch mal gemacht, aber ich habe nie die Prüfung gemacht.
Was sagst du zur Sophos-Firewall?
Habe ich keine Erfahrung mit.
Was sagt eigentlich der Sony-Stream?
Geht da schon irgendwas?
Playstation ist Streaming?
Der YouTube-Stream ist weiter, habt ihr das gesehen?
Wir gucken YouTube.
30 Minuten noch.
Hast du das mit Battlefield 3 mitbekommen?
Ja, ich habe auch schon gesagt, dass ich persönlich bescheuert finde,
ich brauche kein, ich brauche kein Battlefield 3 Remastered.
Battlefield 3 sieht noch so gut aus und ist immer noch so frisch,
dass man da kein Remastered braucht.
Ich glaube, sie machen das nur, um die Zeit zu Battlefield 6 zu überbrücken,
weil sie mit Battlefield 5 verkackt haben.
Bobble sagt, habe gerade mega Probleme mit dem GastwLAN beim DHCP kleint wird.
Die Einstellung rot, keine Ahnung, was das rot bedeutet.
Meinst du, im Router OS Web Interface, rot bedeutet in der Regel...
Ne, grau bedeutet, dass es deaktiviert ist.
Was rot bei DHCP bedeutet, weiß ich jetzt auch gerade nicht.
Aber rot ist immer schlecht, ja, das stimmt.
Gucken wir uns noch ein paar weitere Questions an.
Ja, ich weiß, aber ich habe keine Ahnung, was rot bei DHCP im Router OS bedeutet aus dem Kopf.
Vielleicht, dass er, doch, wahrscheinlich, dass er das DHCP irgendwie nicht starten kann oder so.
Das sagen sie auf jeden Fall.
Hatten wir alles schon, hatten wir auch schon.
Na ja, wegen den Spielen, die es auf der Playstation gibt,
das ist ja der einzige Grund für eine Konsole.
Weil es auf der Konsole Spiele gibt, die es auf dem PC nicht gibt
und wenn man die spielen will, braucht man eine Konsole.
Alle anderen Argumente zählen kaum noch.
Ja, also, ich lasse mir gefallen, wie gesagt, Exklusivspiele,
auch wenn man sagt, ja, ich bin so ein Kacknoob und will halt eine einfache Bedienung haben,
dann ist es auf einer Konsole immer noch angenehmer als auf dem PC,
vor allem, weil man halt nichts rumstellen kann großartig, dementsprechend fängt man auch gar nicht an.
Die Musik hier wieder.
Hast du das 10 Jahre Inscope 21 gesehen, der Kabum wird erwähnt?
Nee, habe ich nicht gesehen.
Ich gehe mal davon aus, dass ich nicht erwähnt werde, sonst hätte ich es wahrscheinlich geschrieben.
So, FIFA, nee, nee, nee.
Hast du mitbekommen, dass Anonymos wurde von UK diese Woche gehackt?
Nee, habe ich nicht mitgekriegt. Echt jetzt?
Hacker sind was?
Die Golem-Seite ist teilweise echt eklig.
Ja, habe ich, ist auch schon fertig, habe auch schon ein paar Runden gespielt.
Es gibt einen Trick, den hat einer auf Twitter geschrieben, den zeige ich euch mal.
Und der hat wirklich funktioniert.
Also ich habe mich ja heute drüber lustig gemacht, wie gut der Download funktioniert im Battle.net von Warzone.
Und da hat einer drunter geschrieben, Region auf Asien stellen, warten bis der Download wieder startet,
pausieren bei der Einstellung, Downloadgeschwindigkeit auf 300 setzen, Download fortsetzen,
dann auf Einstellung ohne pausieren und Downloadspeed wieder auf Null setzen.
Klingt, klingt bescheuert, aber es funktioniert.
Bei mir hat es funktioniert, allerdings geht das dann bloß 10 Minuten oder muss man es wieder machen?
Nach 10 Minuten muss man das ganze wieder machen, allerdings Region umstellen nicht, weil
es könnte aber sein, dass Europa mittlerweile geht, weil die meisten geladen haben.
Aber bei mir hat es funktioniert.
Alter was ist das für Musik?
Telecom Racing, das könnte man Nachfolger kriegen.
Was soll ich mal angucken?
Eazi Unity Media, was?
Was ist das?
Ja habe ich gesehen, dass es auch kacke läuft habe, kann ich mich noch dran erinnern.
Oh jetzt kommt wieder die Big Brain Frage.
Würdest du auf Route Server noch eine externe Firewall installieren oder denkst du für den
einfachen Cloudbetrieb reicht fail to ban IP Tables?
IP Tables reicht für alles.
IP Tables reicht für alles was du brauchst.
Machst einfach alles dicht, bis auf den Port wo du von außen deine Sache ansprichst.
Fail to ban kann auch nicht schaden.
Ich empfehle immer noch, wenn du irgendwas laufen lassen willst, das funktioniert nicht
Leute.
Wenn du irgendwas laufen lassen willst, was von außen erreichbar ist, mach einen Reverse
Proxy davor.
Am besten noch mit Basic Ops, da kannst du nur drauf zugreifen, das ist auch halbwegs
abgesichert.
Ich meine das ist nicht so das Basic Ops jetzt die absolute Big Brain Geschichte wäre.
Aber Firewall alles zumachen, IP Tables alles blocken, außer den Port wo dann ein Reverse
Proxy drauf läuft und dann ist gut.
Was für eine Internetgeschwindigkeit braucht man so für 4 Leute?
Das kommt auf die Leute an.
Ich sage mal so aus dem Bauchhaus unter 50 MBit musst du auf gar keinen Fall anfangen.
Weil ansonsten hast du ja schon Probleme, wenn einer YouTube guckt, einer Netflix so nach
dem Motto.
Ja am besten so schnell wie geht.
50 ist eigentlich zu wenig, wenn alle das Internet ordentlich verwenden.
Dann sollten es wahrscheinlich eher schon Richtung 200 sein.
Besser 400 oder vielleicht.
Also ein paar 4 Leute für eine WG wird schon schnellste nehmen was ich kriegen kann.
Aber das kommt auf die Leute an.
Denkst du mit Bioinformatik kann man was reisen?
Ja ein ehemaliger Azubi von mir oder von uns, wie man es nennen mag, der auch noch eine
Weile danach bei uns gearbeitet hat, mit dem ich mich ganz gut verstanden habe.
Von dem weiß ich, der hat Bioinformatik studiert, der ist bei uns weg, hat angefangen Bioinformatik
zu studieren und der war da voll begeistert.
Ich weiß nicht was er jetzt macht, aber ich hoffe mal, dass das gut läuft bei ihm.
Du darfst dir wünschen, du darfst dir alles wünschen.
Ja das genau, wer Modern Warfare gekauft hat, sollte mit dem Download bevorzugt werden wie
Free2play.
Ganz ehrlich, das fände ich sogar ganz gut.
Nee PC lustig habe ich nicht.
Der Livestream auf Twitch ist besser als auf Judo.
Warum?
Ach so die Qualität.
Ist das so?
Wow, guckt euch das mal an.
Wir werden gucken, welcher Livestream weniger verzögert ist und dann machen wir das.
Video Stats.
Also was haben wir hier für eine Playbackrate?
Naja gut es passiert ja nichts.
Ein Embed und hier haben wir Stats.
Ich habe eine Idee, wisst ihr was wir machen?
Wir machen es im VLC.
Das ist wirklich der Big Brain Move.
Geht nicht.
Warum nicht?
Stream.
Streamlink.
Was Streamlink?
Streamlink?
War Streamlink nicht dieses?
Ah exellent.
Streamlink.
Äh wie hat mein Streamlink überhaupt noch mal gestartet?
Streamlink best?
Wie ging das noch mal?
Ah.
Exellent.
Aber der Stream sah kacke aus.
Der Stream sah pixellig ohne Ende aus.
Hier wirds ja viel besser.
Das sieht hier viel besser aus als im VLC.
Leute eine Viertelstunde gehts los.
Twitch Chat ist komplett am Eskalieren.
Kacke wie?
Ah ich bin hier gar nicht eingeloggt.
Haben die Custom Emotes?
Weiß man nicht.
Vergleichen wir das jetzt mal.
Wir gucken jetzt welcher Stream aktueller ist.
Welcher Stream ist besser?
Hier hat es sich gerade neu aufgebaut.
Der Youtube Stream ist jetzt schneller.
Muss den Chat.
Kann ich den Chat nicht ausblenden?
Chat out.
Ich weiß nicht welcher Stream schneller ist.
Das ist absolut unmöglich.
Wir gucken welcher schneller ist.
Und dann nehmen wir den.
Qualitativ sehe ich keinen Unterschied.
Erhöhe mal die Geschwindigkeit beim Youtube Stream.
So kommt man weiter nach vorne als live.
Wie soll man dann live als live sein?
Chat mal wieder zurück.
Will ja gar nicht zurückspulen.
Wir sehen ja welcher Stream schneller ist.
Sehen wir ja relativ gut gleich.
Spätestens wenn es los geht sehen wir welcher Stream schneller ist.
Twitch ist schneller?
Schwer zu sagen oder?
Schwer zu sagen was davon schneller ist.
Das ist eine Schleife.
Das könnte einfach eine komplette Schleife weiter vorne sein.
Es war kurz Black Screen.
Twitch hatte den zuerst.
Bitrates erkenne ich leider nicht so richtig.
Aber das Audio auf Twitch ist besser mit FFZ Plugin.
Wenn alles nichts hilft gucken wir es uns auf Mixer an.
Also was haben wir hier?
6 MBit und das ist ziemlich gut für so Zeug was die haben.
Und hier erkennt man es halt nicht richtig.
Hier erkenne ich die Bitrate nicht.
Wo ist hier die Bitrate?
Wir gucken es gleich auf TikTok.
Was ist hier die Bitrate?
Connectionspeed?
Nein.
Bitrate müsste immer ein bisschen schwanken.
Er müsste nicht aber meistens schwankt es ein bisschen.
Ich glaube nicht das Connectionspeed die Bitrate vom Video ist.
Wir sehen es gleich.
Alle Kuluki 97.
Stufe 1 für 10 Monate.
Excellent Subscription.
Danke schön.
Huge Subscriber.
Der YouTube Stream hat eine variable Bitrate.
Ja aber ich sehe sie nicht.
Und jetzt kommt noch mehr der Vergleich.
Wie sieht es mit VLC aus?
Wer ist schneller?
Igitt, es laggt.
Wer ist schneller Leute?
Mehr Sony können wir nicht aufhaben.
Du streamst schon über 10 Monate.
Ich stream schon glaube ich seit 2 Jahren oder so.
Wir gucken mal die Bitrate vom VLC.
Ist nicht so gut.
Ach du Scheiße.
Input Bitrate ist ja komplett RIP.
Die Bitrate vom VLC sieht reudig aus.
Warum ist die Bitrate vom VLC so schlecht?
Die Bitrate vom VLC Südl ist mies.
Guckt euch das mal an.
Welcher Streamer die bessere Qualität hat?
Erkenn ich nicht.
Wir können Trick 17 machen.
Wir machen jetzt einfach Stream Link.
Für Twitch auf.
Dann gucken wir uns jetzt da an.
Best.
Wir gucken wahrscheinlich auch Twitch.
Oh guckt mal.
Twitch in VLC sieht ziemlich gut aus.
Was ist hier schneller?
So wir machen mal die Musik aus.
Machen wir mal die Sony Musik an.
Stimmt.
YouTube sieht kacke aus weil es AVP9 ist.
Richtig.
Ich denke auch, dass wir Twitch gucken werden.
Dann gucken wir uns mal hier Bitrate an.
8 Minuten.
Also mehr Playstation Stream können wir nur wirklich nicht aufhaben.
Schau mal ein.
Lautstärke gucken.
Sieht ganz gut aus.
Ach hier Lautstärke wo wir gerade dabei sind.
Das müsste hier viel besser sein.
Dank dem FFZ Audio Kompressor.
Ich finde gerade bei Streams mit Sprache und sowas ist der FFZ Kompressor wirklich ganz
praktisch.
Da hören sich die Sachen gleichmäßiger und teilweise sogar lauter an.
Ohne lauter zu sein.
Hier herrscht Expertise.
Exzellent.
Muss mal gucken ob Teams nicht wieder mal eine Mikrofon Lautstärke umgestellt hat.
Gut, dann werde ich mal so einstellen, dass es für mich angenehm ist von der Lautstärke
und dann mache ich hier hoch.
Schau mal, müssen wir anfangen zu schwätzen.
Du nutzt privat Teams.
Nee, privat würde ich kein Teams verwenden.
Ich bin doch nicht lebensmüde.
Wo kann man den Kompressor einschalten?
Du musst einfach FFZ installieren hier.
Da ist er standardmäßig dabei.
Du musst ihn, ich glaube ausschalten kannst ihn.
Exzellent.
Es wäre praktisch, wenn die eine Uhrzeit mit Sekunden einblenden würden, dass man die
Streams besser sinken kann.
Also was es sinken, gucken kann, welcher schneller ist.
Teams kosten, was ich glaube man kann sich immer noch kostenlos registrieren.
Aber ich bin ja nicht lebensmüde für eine Teams freiwillig privat.
Teams.
Countdown wäre gut.
Ja, schauen wir mal, da kommt bestimmt gleich ein Countdown oder sowas.
Ich würde sagen, so gucken wir uns das an, oder?
Das haben wir doch jetzt perfekt, perfekt gesynkt in der Mitte.
Emote in der Mitte.
Stream in der Mitte.
Triple Stream.
Exzellent.
Genau.
Wahrlich exzellent.
Muss aber noch in den Streamtitel, ich habe im Streamtitel Sony Event stehen, oder?
Müsste eigentlich drin stehen.
Ach dreimal.
Triple Sony Event Stream.
So ist es am besten.
323 Viewer.
Huge.
Prohorn, Twitch Prime, Dankeschön, zwei Monate.
Exzellent Subscription.
Massive Chat IQ Erhöhung.
Ich glaube die meisten.
Ich glaube die meisten Zuschauer, die ich mal hatte, jetzt mal von irgendwelchen Hosts
ausgenommen, waren mal bei einem Apple Event 800 oder 750 oder sowas.
Wo sich dann sogar ein paar beschwert haben, dass ich Apple geflamed habe.
Also richtig Apple Fanboys am Start.
Das ist heute auch so.
PlayStation Fanboys sind die schlimmsten.
Robinson Stufe eins.
Dankeschön.
Huge Subscription.
Vertrückt mich übrigens, ich will gar nicht MonkaS sagen.
Ich will eigentlich Subscriber sagen, aber der Knopf ist fast nebeneinander.
Heute wird nicht gehatet.
Heute wird einfach gesagt, was ich dazu denke und ich bin da recht neutral.
Wo kam zuerst Stay Tuned Leute?
Wo kam zuerst Stay Tuned?
Ach ja Leute, soll ich den Chat ausblenden?
Ich blende den Chat aus.
Wir machen den Chat weg.
Chat deleted.
Ich glaube, die neue PlayStation läuft bestimmt auf.
Hey, die PlayStation läuft auf BSD.
Geht doch alles.
She baited mich nicht, Chat.
Die PlayStation läuft auf BSD.
Das ist jetzt kein She Bait.
Die PlayStation läuft auf die PlayStation schon, glaube ich, seit der PS2.
Weil nur 48 FPS, naja, der offizielle Stream ist in 30 FPS.
Wir sind immer noch schneller als der offizielle Stream.
Oh, ach ne.
Ich glaube, also der YouTube Stream ist ewig hinten dran, wenn ich das gerade richtig gesehen habe.
Das Team war zuerst, danach kommt VLC oder auch nicht.
Ah, das ist schwer zu sagen.
Nein, wir machen heute kein Bullshit Bingo, passt schon.
Stay Tuned war zuerst bei YouTube, okay.
Aber man hatte es überhaupt nicht erkannt, den PlayStation, den Twitch Stream.
Wir nehmen das, was die beste Quali ist.
Ja, Twitch, Twitch und VLC.
YouTube ist ja, ich habe alles Maximum Quali.
Leute, es geht los jetzt.
22 Uhr.
Okay.
Welcher Stream wird es?
Jetzt werden auch Wetten angenommen.
Welchen gucken wir uns an?
Wo geht es zuerst los?
TikTok, ja TikTok glaube ich auch.
Die Musik.
Soll ich mal gucken, ob es im Internet Explorer läuft?
Da ist bestimmt noch schneller.
Wir sind sowas von Tuned.
Jetzt, jetzt.
Okay, Twitch ist am schnellsten.
Excellent.
Ihr müsst mir gleich sagen, ob die Lautstärke passt.
Ich mache mal volle Pulle.
Ich mache volle Pulle Lautstärke.
Und dann müsst ihr mir sagen, ob es passt.
Ob zu laut, zu leise, zu sonst was.
Scheint zu passen.
Ich verschiebe mal meine Bildchen kurz ein bisschen auf die Seite.
Okay, wir feiern uns erstmal ein bisschen selbst.
Ein neues LittleBigPlanet, das wäre doch was.
Boi.
Final Fantasy Remake, Loll.
Das wäre dem Leben nichts.
Was kommt jetzt?
GTA 5 auch für die Plays?
Oh nee, oder?
Warum ist es PS4?
Da oben steht PS4.
Aber wenn sie GTA zeigen, hätten sie PS3 zeigen müssen.
Weil das kam ursprünglich auf der PS3.
Aha.
Zumindest wissen wir jetzt, dass die Lautstärke gut passt.
Expanded and Enhanced.
Sag ich doch, das ist eine Ankündigung für die PS5.
Das gibt es jetzt für die PS3, für die PS4 und für die PS5.
Oh, okay, ich hab nix gesagt.
Es gibt nix, es ist kostenlos.
Ich hab nix gesagt, es ist kostenlos, ist okay.
Kost ist in Ordnung.
GTA Cash.
Moment.
Jetzt ist sogar schon Konsolenkauf, Pay to Win.
Und was hat man davon, wenn das jeder kriegt?
Egal.
Jetzt, jetzt hier.
Also eins muss man sagen, ihr Logo animieren können sie gut.
Das machen sie ja schon seit 30 Minuten.
Richtig.
Oh.
Leute, Skyrim?
Skyrim, PS5?
Skyrim muss auf aller Plattform.
Okay.
Jetzt, jetzt geht's los.
Spider-Man?
Nee.
Keine Ahnung.
Das würde zu Sony passen.
Spoda, Spodas.
Ja, also Spodaman.
Ist das der gleiche Spider-Man wie aus dem Animated-Film?
Ah, anscheinend, ja.
Ah, Gran Turismo.
Gran Turismo.
Okay, Autorennspiel.
Okay.
Ja.
Gibt bestimmt genug, denen das gefällt, aber Gran Turismo, genauso wie Forza ist nicht
mein Genre.
Mein Genre ist es nicht, nicht mein Genre.
Wetter.
Das sah cool aus, muss man ihn lassen.
Also, bei den Autos, ich gehe auch gar nicht.
Sieben.
Oh, sieben sind die schon.
Ich hab noch nicht eins davon gespielt.
Sarah.
Oh, Campaign Mode.
Sarah hat schon so eine coole, coole Tuning-Mütze auf.
Auch Schröder ist dabei.
Da kann nichts passieren, wenn Schröder dabei ist.
Und Leitner auch.
Leute, wer kennt sich mit Rennspielen aus?
Gibt's die Leute echt?
Gibt's die?
Ist das, ist das, ist das Lizenz?
Ist das Lizenz oder sind das Random-Namen?
Ich hab, ich hab keinen blassen Schimmer.
Random.
Wie, wie Lehmann ist der Bruder von Jens Lehmann?
Ah, verstehe.
Random.
Also, wenn das Xbox-Namen wären, dann würde der hier schon xxquickscope360 heißen.
Okay, das war Resident Sleeper.
Next.
Was kommt denn jetzt?
Aua.
Okay, das Chat flippt aus.
Kann ich nicht mitreden, ich hab die Serie nicht gespielt.
Dankeschön Homer, 0818.
Aber es sieht sehr abwechslungsreich aus.
Was da vorne am Ende im Game sein wird, mal gucken.
Was ist denn das, ist das eher Jump and Run?
Oder was darf ich mir da drunter vorstellen, Chat?
Okay.
Too late.
Kill Ratchet.
Ah, okay.
Ah, nee.
Okay, es soll zumindest den Anschein erwecken, als wäre es in-Game.
Es ist wahrscheinlich auch in-Game.
Aber es ist halt wieder nur ein kleiner Ausschnitt, der einfach jetzt besonders gut das Ganze darstellen soll.
Also, was am Ende rauskommt, muss ich mal zeigen.
Aber ich hab absolut keine Erwartungen sonst viel zu dem Game, ich hab keinen Plan, nie gespielt.
Was passiert da überhaupt gerade?
Ja, eins muss man sagen.
Mehr Gameplay als die letzten Male zeigen sie tatsächlich.
Und wenigstens auch sowas wie Gameplay und nicht nur irgendwelchen schönen Trailer.
Gut, das sieht jetzt für mich jetzt als ein absolut Unkenntnis, der absolut keine Kenntnisse dieser Serie hat.
Jetzt irgendwie ein bisschen langweilig aus, aber ich glaube, da darf man sich nicht so viel reininterpretieren.
Das war eher so, okay, Champ.
Noch nicht, da ist der Hype Train, der braucht noch ein bisschen.
Oh, jetzt kommt bestimmt das Final Fantasy Remake, das nie fertig wird.
Oder auch nicht.
Doch, wahrscheinlich schon.
Nee, wahrscheinlich eher nicht.
Was ist das?
Ist das ein neues Final Fantasy?
Oder ist das was ganz Besonderes?
Okay, ja.
Man konnte da jetzt nicht viel rausbläsen.
Aber neue Spiele, ich bin immer ein Riesenfan davon, neue Sachen.
Und nicht der 85. Aufguss von irgendeiner Serie, da bin ich immer sofort dabei.
Kommt bestimmt Destiny oder irgendwie sowas.
Was ist das denn?
Es ist ein Spiel mit Katzen, das ist schon mal gut.
Ausgusspunkte.
Oh, das könnte was für mich sein.
Es schnurrt, hört ihr es?
Das war mal ein Game für mich.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, um was es geht, aber das war es für mich.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, um was es geht.
Das war es für mich.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, um was es geht, aber das war es für mich.
WTF, was ist da los?
Ich bin irgendwie anders, als wenn es ändert.
Dieses Weltall wird Teil von mir.
Das beeinflusst mein Geist, meine Erinnerungen.
Je länger ich hier lebe, desto mehr kann ich meine Sanheit wechseln.
Ich kann keine Hoffnung verlieren.
Das war weder Quickscope noch hat sie sich gedreht. Das ist nicht accepted.
Ist das so John Wick Dishonored oder was?
Okay.
Ich wollte jetzt gerade gucken.
Ich wollte jetzt gerade gucken ob der Twitch zu ihm wieder funktioniert.
Okay. Geht der Twitch zu ihm wieder?
Alter, der sieht besser aus.
Nein, der Twitch. Das gucken wir noch auf YouTube danach.
What the fuck.
Wir müssen doch. Der Sound spackt.
Noch mehr Horror Spiele oder was?
Wie hat er da vorbeigeschossen? What the fuck? Der stand zwei Meter vor ihm.
Das hatte 5 FPS. Das lief mit ungefähr 5 FPS was man da gerade gesehen hat. Das hat echt hardcore geruckelt.
Das sieht nicht aus wie Resident Evil irgendwie Leute.
Vielleicht ist es Minecraft 2.
Village.
Ah, es ist so ein Resident Evil Spinoff.
Einmal reicht nicht.
Oder ist es wirklich ein richtiges, echtes, neues Resident Evil? Okay.
Das ist eigentlich ganz nice.
Schnell auf Twitch. Wir sind schon auf Twitch PC lustig. Das ist schon wieder Twitch.
Ah, das ist eine 8. Village 8. Das ist ja Big Brain, Alter.
Was ist das?
Was passiert da?
Rackmata. Ah ja.
Was ist das?
Irgendwie ist es, irgendwie sah das jetzt trotzdem ganz cool aus. Ich kann mir nichts, keinen Reim drunter machen. Keinen Reim drauf machen.
Hm?
Wie heißt das denn? Rackmata anscheinend.
Rackmata. Keine Ahnung, was das Geschehen cool aussprechen sollte.
Das wievielte Playstation-Logo war das jetzt?
Sony. Okay, war es von Sony selbst.
Was ist das jetzt? Horizon Zero Dawn 2. Nee, oder?
Ist das Horizon 2?
Weiß nicht, dafür sind zu wenig Maschinen, oder?
Das ist Aloy Sprecherin? Ja dann wird es wahrscheinlich so sein.
Guck mal, eine Crap. Aber das müssten alles Maschinen sein.
Oh, anscheinend. Ah. Jetzt ist klar, jetzt ist klar.
Jetzt ist klar. Aber die Animationen sind immer wieder huge.
Oh, mit Unterwasserstells.
Jetzt war von Ezio was abgucken sollen.
Ja gut, jetzt wissen wir ja schon, was es ist. Das war ja abdem man die Hauptdarstellerin gesehen hat schon klar.
Ich musste den ersten Teil erstmal spielen.
Ich glaube jetzt ist fertig. Ich glaube jetzt ist fertig. Oder? Das ist so eine Art Zusammenfassung.
Gta war doch ganz am Anfang. Aber zum Abschluss, ja ich denke auch, dass zum Abschluss noch was kommen muss.
Ich glaube auch, da kommt noch ein bisschen was. Oder? Oder? Ich meine, das wäre so ein typisches Outro Video.
Jetzt Konsolenreveal.
Sieht aus wie ein unfertiges Stück aus meinem 3D-Druck.
Jetzt übertreibt man nicht, Sony. Zeigt halt mal.
Ja. Nein. Nein. Doch. Ja. Ah. Ok, sie hat Hörner.
Aber es sieht aus wie eine Playstation. Ganz ehrlich, ein bisschen geschwungener. Aber es sieht halt aus wie eine Konsole.
Da ist jetzt nichts. Es könnte genauso gut die neue Fritzbox sein, wenn die Farbe stimmt.
Es sieht aus wie so eine Konsolenbox. Es sieht ok aus. Man kann sie zumindest nicht mehr falsch herum hinstellen. Das ist auch schon mal gut.
Es sieht ok aus, aber ich meine für mich muss das auch nicht toll aussehen. Hauptsache es ist gut, was es drauf für Games gibt.
Ja, stylischer als die Xbox ist ja auch echt kein Grund. Die Xbox sieht ja auch hässlich aus. Oh guck mal, es gibt sogar welche ohne optisches Laufwerk.
Digital Edition nennt man das jetzt. Aha. Ich kann meine Spiele nicht mehr verkaufen Edition nenne ich das. Kamera.
Also ich werde es mir ohne Laufwerk kaufen. Hauptsache wenn da groß genug Speicher drin ist. Jetzt fertig.
Kommt noch was?
Also es soll jetzt eigentlich ist jetzt ja fertig, aber vielleicht kommt noch irgendwie noch so was dickes hinten drauf.
Aber doch gerade schon.
Oh, die Katze guckt. Die Katze guckt mich kritisch an. Läuft da drauf was mit über 60 FPS? Tja, da bin ich auch mal gespannt.
Der offizielle Stream ist ja nur 30 FPS.
Okay, vielleicht kommt ja noch mal eine fette Sache hinten drauf. Aber ich glaube nicht. Das sieht einfach zu sehr nach Outro Video aus.
Das ist das Lüftergeräusch von der PS5. Der war gut. Das Lüftergeräusch. Preis gibt es nicht. Den wahren Playstation Fan interessiert der Preis doch nicht.
Der kauft sich eh alles. Okay, fertig. Es kommt doch nichts großes mehr hinten drauf. Fertig.
Okay, ich muss euch ganz ehrlich sagen. Wisst ihr was mir am besten gefallen hat? Also mir hat tatsächlich das neue Little Big Planet Spiel am besten gefallen.
Wenn es was taugt. Wenn es was taugt, ja. Das letzte war schon nicht mehr so gut. Grafisch war da jetzt nichts aufregendes dabei, sagt der Chat. Ja, was sollen sie denn großartig machen?
Spiele sehen ja heutzutage nicht mehr einfach auf einen Schlag doppelt so gut aus wie vorher. Was sollen sie denn großartig machen?
Die Webcam war die überzeugendste überhaupt. Der Journey Nachfolger. Mal gucken was da rauskommt. 2 Terapeit soll 599 kosten. Ist das nicht neuer Viewer Rekord? Keine Ahnung.
Ja, Pfund und Europreis wird doch wahrscheinlich relativ ähnlich sein.
Ja gut. Also was soll ich sagen? So 100% nicht geschockt hat es mich jetzt nicht. Hab ich aber ehrlich gesagt auch nicht erwartet.
Weil die letzten Sony Präsentationen schon echt extrem Resident Sleeper waren. Die wurden bloß noch, finde ich, ne, ne, gar nicht. Microsoft hat wenigstens Trailer gezeigt im Vergleich zu Sony früher. Aber sowohl Microsoft als auch Sony waren beides echt ultra Resident Sleeper bisher.
Also ja, ich kann jetzt echt gar nichts großartig zu sagen ehrlich gesagt. Mach mal ne Umfrage Zwecks Design. Für was? Achso von der Playstation.
Das muss ich auch keine Umfrage machen. Gerade das Design ist Geschmackssache. Ich muss sagen es sieht halt aus wie ein WLAN Router im Endeffekt. Da ist jetzt nichts wahnsinnig geniales im Design dabei.
Es sieht halt aus wie so ne Hardware Kiste mit Zeug drin. Nicht mal ganz so eckig wie früher, aber es ist auch nichts weltbewegendes.
Ja, Spatzgranat, das rechnen sieht ein bisschen aus wie Alienware.
Warum auf einmal weiß... Mich würd's nicht wundern, wenn's die in mehreren Farben sogar gibt.
Es ist doch grad im Trend, dass man Sachen mit mehreren Farben anbietet. Und das kannst du bei der Konsole, sieht ja auch so aus, als könntest du die Seitenteile ganz gut tauschen.
Zumindest beim Herstellen, da relativ einfach unterschiedliche Seitenteile dran machen. Und dann gibt's die dann in Pink, in Weiß, in Schwarz, in Silber, in was auch immer. Könnt ich mir gut vorstellen.
Wieso kein Skyrim? Du kannst drauf wetten, Skyrim kommt noch. Skyrim kommt für jede Plattform. Und außerdem ist das Ding ja rückwärts kompatibel für die PS4. Gibt's Skyrim überhaupt für die PS4?
Fritzbox Station, es sieht ein bisschen aus wie ne neue Fritzbox, ja das stimmt.
Nix zu Battlefield 6, nix zum neuen CoD, nee gab's nix, ja. Wie ist eure Meinung? Man hat nicht allzu viel gesehen. Die Konsole sieht aus wie ne Fritzbox, in Weiß.
Au, ich bin ja gleich um ein Nas gekommen. Wie gesagt, ich hab ja letztens übelst die Nas am Gelände angehauen, aber jetzt voll den blauen Black.
Max jetzt nach dem Review, welche Konsole sagt ihr im Moment mehr zu? Weder noch, ich kauf die mir zum Release diesmal eh nicht. Ich werde mir diesmal, Leute ihr kennt mich, ich sag das jetzt und wahrscheinlich kauf ich sie mir trotzdem, aber ich werde mir diesmal zum Release keine Konsole kaufen.
Ich hab mir sowohl die PS4 als auch die Xbox One zur Release gekauft. Ich hab hier noch, hier liegt er, Leute hier liegt er, der Controller. Day One 2013 steht drauf.
Und ganz ehrlich, ich hab diese Konsolengeneration fast nie verwendet. So gut wie gar nicht. Sowohl Xbox als auch Playstation. Und die Zwischengeneration hat's eh verkackt.
Mittlerweile ist ein PC langlebiger als eine Konsolengeneration, wenn man sich die Zwischengeschichte anguckt mit PS4 Pro und Xbox. Bei Xbox hab ich schon wieder vergessen, wie das Ding heißt. Xbox Benamung ist ja eh jenseits von gut und böse.
Preis? Nein, Preis wurde nicht genannt. Die Switch hab ich auch nicht so viel benutzt, weil für die Switch gibt's kaum gescheite Games. Das wäre so ein bisschen das Nintendo Problem.
Es gibt so vier, fünf Sachen, die sind cool und der Rest ist auf jeder anderen Plattform besser. Außer man möchte natürlich die Switch mitnehmen, dann ist es gut.
Ja, das würde mich auch mal interessieren, ob man, wie laut die Playstation ist, die neue. Ob sie das gut gekühlt bekommen.
Aber das nächste, was bei mir erst mal ansteht, ist weder eine Konsole, weder eine Playstation oder eine Xbox zu release, sondern wenn AMD eine neue CPU rausbringt und Nvidia eine neue Grafikkartengeneration, dass ich mir einen neuen Rechner hol.
Ist nicht so, dass mein Rechner schlecht ist, aber mir juckt es schon seit Ende letzten Jahres in den Fingern. Ich will mir einen neuen Rechner holen und es lohnt sich aktuell einfach noch nicht.
Erträgliches, aber wahrscheinlich ist das eher für ihr komisches 3D Soundgedöns, was wir da das letzte Mal angepriesen haben. Ich hab keinen Ryzen, ich hab noch einen 8700K.
Ich hab letztes Jahr überlegt, ob ich mir nicht einen Ryzen kaufe, aber ich bin dann zu dem Schluss gekommen, es lohnt sich nicht, jetzt einen neuen PC zu kaufen.
Sobald es die neuen CPUs von AMD gibt und sobald es eine neue Grafikkartengeneration von Nvidia gibt, wird gekauft.
Ich brauch was Neues an Hardware.
Früher hab ich mich geärgert, da hab ich ganz scheiße, ich muss mir alle zwei Jahre einen neuen Gamingrechner kaufen, zu Zeiten wo ich noch kein Geld hatte und nichts verdient habe und keine Kohle hatte. Und jetzt wo ich genug Geld hab, sag ich, ich kann mein Geld nicht ausgeben. Genau das umgedrehte Problem.
Für Warzone neuen Rechner, nee. Warzone läuft auch so ganz gut. Warzone ist halt an manchen Stellen verbackter Crap.
Aber wofür brauchst du einen neuen? Haben. Ja wunderbar, jetzt wissen wir Bescheid oder auch nicht.
Warum sind da so viele Monka Esse? Huge Monka Esse.
Ich soll den Chat ein, ach stimmt ja, den Chat können wir wieder einplenden.
Da ist der Chat.
Ja, Leute, ich bin ja ein bisschen enttäuscht, bin ich ja schon. Ich hab jetzt nicht so den Wahnsinnshype erwartet, aber ich hab gedacht, das ist vielleicht der ein oder andere richtige Knaller dabei, wo ich sag, Scheiße damit hab ich nicht gerechnet, aber das ist geil. Es ging so, es war jetzt nicht total scheiße, es war schon okay.
Was hältst du von VR? Es gibt zu wenig Spiele.
Der eins, jetzt mal ernsthaft, VR-Spiele außer Half-Life gibt's ja kaum was. Und Resident Evil, Half-Life und Resident Evil. Gibt's ja kaum wirklich richtige Must-Have-VR-Spiele, wofür sich's lohnt, sowas zu kaufen. Und das einzige, wofür sich's lohnt, ist, falls es Leute gibt, die sich VR-Porn angucken wollen.
Für die mag sich eine VR-Brille lohnen, aber ich hab's bis jetzt noch nicht eingesehen, mir eine 3D-Brille oder eine VR-Brille zu kaufen für ein Game, was ich spielen will.
Choose my name, tu dir keinen Zwang an. Und VR-Chat, ja, wenn's einem gefällt. Das einzige, was ich weiß, oder das einzige, was ich kenne von VR-Chat, ist Uganda Knuckles.
Ansonsten ging das voll an mir vorbei. Weiß man schon, ob die Digital Edition ohne Laufwerk billiger werden wird? Weiß man nicht. Ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass sie so symbolisch billiger wird, so 10 Dollar oder so.
Oder sie hat mehr Speicher und ist teurer. Oder was auch immer. Warum wird man nicht Alexi-Bexi empfohlen? Das kann ich mir nicht geben.
Hast du eigentlich Windows-LTS? Nö.
Man kann die Playstation 5 wohl auch flach hinlegen. Ja, gehe ich auch fort aus. Das wäre auch ziemlich bescheuert, wenn sie das nicht ermöglichen würden. Außer sie wollen, dass die Leute ihre Konsole permanent kaputt machen, weil sie die umschmeißen.
Was ist denn heute? Heute ist Donnerstag. Morgen ist ja gar kein Aufwachen-Stream-Chat.
Maman da. Irgendwie habe ich im Kopf gedacht, es wäre heute Samstag und morgen ist Aufwachen-Stream. Morgen habe ich frei. Morgen ist ja gar kein Sonntag. Morgen Früh-Stream. Wie viele von euch am Urlaub? Oder umgedreht gefragt, wer muss von euch arbeiten gehen und wer hat morgen frei?
Arbeiten. Frei. Ich nicht. Wehtschicht. Igitt.
Arbeiten. Brückentag. Also die meisten müssen wohl...
Nee. Ich würde sagen halbe halbe. Halbe halbe mit dem Trend, dass wohl ein bisschen mehr arbeiten müssen als...
Home-Office, da zahlt sich kein Urlaubstag aus. Bei mir war es so, ich musste 60% meines Urlaubs verplanen. Und da habe ich noch einen Tag genommen, den habe ich gebraucht, um bis 60% zu kommen.
Spätschicht. Weil das nichts für mich wäre. Frühschicht ist besser. Also wenn ich Schicht arbeiten muss, müsste, würde ich immer Frühschicht machen, dass ich früh gehen kann.
Das mache ich ja jetzt im Prinzip auch schon fast. Ich stehe ja 5.45 Uhr auf, dass ich 15.30 Uhr heimgehen kann. Ansonsten würde ich erst 17.30 Uhr heimgehen. Das wäre mir viel zu spät.
Nachtschichtzulage. Dann ist es was anderes. Bei uns der Support bekommt auch am Wochenende Zulage. Und an Feiertagen. Und nachts. Und am besten an Feiertagen nachts.
Da streiten sie sich immer, wer die Schicht machen darf. Ja, ich gehe eher früh ins Bett und stehe früh auf und bin dafür auch früh wieder daheim.
Anstatt zu umgedreht.
Ja, mehr gibt es zur Playstation 5 jetzt echt nicht zu sagen. Wir müssen mal abwarten, was da rauskommt. Also ich werde, wie gesagt, ich werde mir weder die Xbox noch die Playstation 5 kaufen zu Release.
Ha, Eiskäuter. Richtig gute Idee. Big Brain. Big Brain.
Ich nehme aber auch immer Dezember komplett frei.
Dezember bin ich immer komplett daheim. Hat Spaß gemacht, dass ihr mir sagt, Coilboy. Das ist sehr schön. Sehr, sehr, sehr nice.
Ne, glaube ich nicht, dass ich, ne, ne, ich glaube, ich bestelle mir keine PS5. Also vorbestellen werde ich die PS5 auf jeden Fall nicht.
Excellent ist das, genau. Vorbestellen werde ich es auf gar keinen Fall. Und ich gehe auch ziemlich sicher davon aus, dass ich mir diesmal nicht zu Release kaufen würde.
Werde. Weil ich habe, ich habe mir die anderen beiden zu Release gekauft und ich habe sie nie verwendet, so gut wie nie.
Riecht Monarch S. Mal gucken, ob sie Lüftergeräusche in Griff kriegen.
Battlefield 6 könnte ein Reboot sein. Im Prinzip ist jedes Battlefield ein Reboot.
Halt mit einem gemeinsamen Gameplay Kern. Hat Microsoft schon was vorgestellt? Ja, war doch letztens erst diese Xbox Trailer Stream. Den konnte ich aber leider nicht streamen. Ich glaube, da hatte ich keine Zeit an dem Tag.
Ja, ja, die haben irgendwelche Trailer vorgestellt. Da war aber jetzt auch nichts dabei, was mich rausgeschockt hat.
Oh Leute, ich bin müde. Ich glaube, ich gehe jetzt gleich pennen. Ich glaube, ich gehe jetzt pennen.
Das war so geil. Lass noch mal angucken.
Wann kommt commentary auf YouTube? Weiß ich doch nicht. Ich habe ein richtig geiles Warzone Gameplay, was ich hochladen wollte.
Okay Leute, also wir sehen uns dann. Mal gucken, vielleicht morgen früh schon. Bis denn. Wir sehen uns. Macht's gut.
Oh Gott, oh Gott!
=======
So, und jetzt ist...
Okay, wo finde ich jetzt meine Clips?
Jetzt muss man wissen.
Man muss wissen, es ist kein Indikator dafür.
Man muss auf dieses, auf den Avatar klicken, dass man überhaupt das Menü bekommt dafür.
Das weiß man nicht.
Also es gibt keiner Indikator für.
Das ist mega schlechtes UI Design irgendwie.
So, und wenn man das weiß, aus dem Ruck, wie gesagt, die Seite ruckelt wie Sau.
Guckt euch das mal an.
So, dann geht man auf Videos.
Dann geht man hier oben hin auf Featured Clips.
Das ist total umständlich.
Warum trenntet meine...
Warum trenntet er was mit der Katze?
Oder was er trenntet?
So ist die Katze nachgemacht, aber Alter.
Das ist fast schon Windows-Menüführung.
Ach Gott, und Michael 50 Billion ist auch am Start.
Excellent.
Also es geht, ich denke mal, dass es kurz vor 22 Uhr losgeht.
Mit irgendwie Pre-Show oder sonst was.
Offiziell um 22 Uhr.
Schreiben sie ja auch hier 95 Minuten und eineinhalb Stunden.
Gucken wir mal.
Schauen wir mal.
Also.
Genau, genau, Emix Risen.
Ich verstehe den Sinn nicht davon, warum man das jetzt 5 Mal klicke muss, wo vorher einmal ging.
Und eins muss man ja mal sagen.
Die Twitch-Webseite.
Die war jetzt noch nie irgendwie die absolute Augenweide.
Es ist jetzt nicht so, dass ich auf Twitch gegangen bin.
Boah, ist das eine tolle, toll designte Experience hier.
Ist das toll und sonst was.
Aber Twitch war eigentlich relativ zweckmäßig.
Das neue Design macht es nicht hübscher, aber auch nicht wirklich besser.
Es macht es an vielen Stellen nur komplizierter.
Also ich persönlich verstehe den Sinn nicht davon.
Was mir einleuchtet ist, dass man jetzt die Profilbilder customisieren kann.
Das finde ich gut.
Ach stimmt, wo ist denn hier?
YouTube, gucken wir hier, das ist doch...
Excellent.
Ist das der hier?
Gehe ich mal voraus, oder?
YouTube PlayStay.
Ich gucke mal, was schreiben eigentlich die Games dazu?
Playstation.
Achso, das ist ja nicht die GameStar, die da was zu schreiben.
Das ist ja die GamePro, die da was zu schreiben.
Weil die haben es ja mit Konsolen sonst nicht so.
Playstation Event, Reveal Event.
Was ist denn der offizielle Stream auf YouTube?
Hier, den da.
Das ist der Stream, den ich aufhabe.
Ja, das ist der Stream, den ich aufhabe, hier schon.
Gibt es das auch in German?
Deutsch, die Zukunft des Gaming.
Wir gucken uns...
Ok Leute, ihr dürft es euch aussuchen.
So, wollen wir es uns in Deutsch angucken oder in Original?
Japanisch.
Japanisch wäre auch was.
Gibt es das überhaupt auf Japanisch?
Ja, hier.
Wie heißt Playstation eigentlich auf Japanisch?
So wahrscheinlich.
Nee, wir gucken uns das auf Englisch an.
Gibt es denn da schon Prediction?
Playstation 5?
Was schreiben denn irgendwelche komischen Leute?
Ich habe von den Seiten nichts gehört.
Was?
Ach, das ist wo die Leute schreiben, was sie gerne hätten.
Also ich habe ja persönlich keine Erwartungen und keine Ahnung davon.
Weil ich die Playstation 4 zwar zur Release gekauft habe,
aber quasi 5 Stunden anhatte oder so.
Na ja, 30, 40 Stunden insgesamt vielleicht.
Dance Dance Revolution Mario, ist das denn Ihr Ernst?
Ich wusste gar nicht, dass dieses Spiel überhaupt existiert.
Future of Gaming Predictions.
Ja, Predictions.
Console Hardware, gut, dazu werden sie was erzählen.
Und das Ding wird nicht so aussehen.
Oder?
Nein, das wird nicht so aussehen.
Das Ding wird relativ klassisch aussehen, wie bisher.
Die Xbox ist ja so ein komischer Würfel.
Horizon Zero Dawn 2, möglich.
Eigentlich ist es mir persönlich ziemlich wurscht, was die bei Sony machen.
Ich hoffe nur, dass sich die Plattform wieder lohnt.
Also ich werde es mir wahrscheinlich nicht zur Release kaufen,
aber ich werde es mir irgendwann kaufen.
Dann hoffe ich, dass es was Gescheites gibt.
30 FPS 1080p, by the way.
Man hofft ja auch, dass Call of Duty irgendwas ankündigt.
Und es gibt ja die Gerüchte, dass das neue Call of Duty einfach nur Black Ops heißen wird.
Was absolut komplett hirnverbrannt ist.
Wenn du mal überlegst, das letzte Black Ops hieß 4,
das heißt Black Ops gab es schon.
Und wenn Black Ops Release, also neues Black Ops,
was einfach nur Black Ops heißt, nicht Black Ops 1 ist,
sondern einfach nur Black Ops und nach Black Ops 4 jetzt erscheint.
Was ist mit denen los?
Ich weiß es nicht.
Playstation VR 2.
Na ja.
Freut ihr euch auf irgendwas?
Also vielleicht haben wir ja den einen oder anderen,
der viel Playstation spielt.
Ist für euch irgendwas dabei, wo ihr sagt,
oh ja, da warte ich drauf.
Ja, Battlefield verkackt es auch richtig mit der Benahmung.
Likely Call of Duty Black Ops, die Benahmung.
Ich kriege echt Anfänge.
Bloodborne Remastered, Who Cares, Resident Evil 8.
Ach, juckt mich auch nicht wirklich.
Ich habe den ersten Teil nicht mal gespielt.
Also ja, warum nicht?
Killzone X.
Och nee, ein neues Killzone brauche ich nicht wirklich.
Das wäre cool.
Allerdings vielleicht mit irgendeinem besseren Namen.
Assassin's Creed juckt mich beim besten Willen gerade gar nicht.
Schauen wir mal.
World of War 2 gibt es auch schon für Playstation 2.
Jaja, die ganzen Spiele gab es alle schon mal.
Auch Black Ops gab es schon.
Total Fail im Endeffekt.
So, 88 Minuten.
Was macht man denn so lange?
Oh, oh, nee.
Oh, wird das Ganze auch auf Mixer gestreamt?
Auf Mixer gibt es keinen Playstation Channel.
Was denn da los?
Ist Mixer zu unbedeutend?
Und ist Mixer zu Microsoft?
Black Mesa Let's Play.
Ich habe Black Mesa hier glaube ich schon zweimal im Stream durchgespielt.
Wie oft soll ich das nochmal?
Okay, nein, sorry.
Nicht komplett durchgespielt.
Weil das eine Sendung ist so kacke.
Da hatte ich keinen Bock drauf.
Hast du auf dem Discord die Battlefield News gesehen?
Nee, Sebaro.
Kannst du mal einen Link schicken?
Also ich habe gelesen, dass ergeblich Battlefield 3 Remake schon eine Weile in der Mache ist.
Hier, guck mal, da steht es doch.
Aber ich will kein Battlefield 3 Remake.
Ich will kein Battlefield 3 Remake.
Battlefield 3 war mein Lieblingsbattlefield bei Company 2.
Aber das ist nicht, also erstens ist das nicht alt genug und schlecht genug vom Technik,
dass es in Remake irgendwie rechtfertigen würde.
Und außerdem, ich will ein neues, gutes Battlefield, was lange supportet wird.
Das einzige was sein kann ist, dass die Battlefield 3 Remastered raushauen.
Remastered?
Was willst du überhaupt am Battlefield 3 großartig remasteren?
Das Game sieht sogar heute noch ziemlich gut aus.
Und ich könnte mir vorstellen, die wollen jetzt einfach die Zeit überbrücken.
Vielleicht im Battlefield auf Steam.
Die wollen die Zeit wahrscheinlich überbrücken.
Ich muss übrigens mal was trinken, weil ich habe irgendwie einen trockenen Hals.
Und wenn ich jetzt noch 2 Stunden, 3 Stunden laber.
Ist das hier der Almighty, Almighty Duck, der auch schon die anderen Sachen geleakt hat?
Ja, ne, das ist er.
Geh ich mal von aus.
Der heißt plus jetzt anders.
Ja, also es wäre ein logischer Zug, dass man Battlefield 3 Remastered raushaut,
weil man muss ja irgendwie bis zum Battlefield 6 Release überbrücken.
Allerdings, ich brauche es nicht.
Battlefield 3 ist vollkommen in Ordnung.
Ja, mal schauen.
Ich meine, es wäre natürlich geil, wenn das Game dadurch ein bisschen mehr bevölkert wird.
Aber im Endeffekt wollen die einfach nur die alten Fans noch mal neu abfrühstücken.
Ich meine, ich habe Battlefield 3 gekauft auf 3 Plattformen.
Inklusive Battle Pass, ne, wie hieß das?
Hieß das Battle Pass?
Ne, Battle Pass ist das in Call of Duty.
Wie hieß denn das?
Premium.
Und sonst was.
Also mehr Geld für Battlefield 3 muss ich ehrlich gesagt nicht ausgeben.
Man kann Battlefield 3 heute noch spielen.
Ein bisschen vollere Server wären gut, aber dazu muss man eher zu Battlefield 4 gehen,
weil man quasi einen Modern Warfare Style Battlefield spielen will.
Hab ich eigentlich mein Dingsprogramm?
Ja, Aufzeichnungsprogramm.
Welche Ryzen-CPU möchtest du in der Zukunft kaufen?
Ja, am liebsten einen Ryzen 4950X.
Aber den gibt es ja noch nicht.
Ja.
Den würde ich mir am liebsten kaufen, wenn es einen gäbe.
Und dazu eine 3080 Ti.
Spielst du auch FIFA?
Ne.
Also das einzige, was ich aktuell spiele, ist Warzone und Path of Exile.
Ah ja.
Ob ich jetzt nicht was da heute großartig kommen könnte.
Ich hoffe mal, dass der Stream spannender wird wie der letzte.
Die letzten Playstation-Streams, ich kann mich an die letzten Playstation-Streams noch erinnern.
Das war zwar eine Developer-Rede, aber selbst aus technischer Sicht fand ich es langweilig.
Und die anderen Sony-Sachen, die wir gesehen haben, die waren echt hardcore Resident-Sleeper.
Microsoft war auch ziemlich Resident-Sleeper.
Was ich bei Microsoft immer lustig finde, nicht dass es bei Sony großartig anders wäre,
was ich bei Microsoft immer lustig finde, vor jedem Scheiß, egal ob es Weltpremiere ist oder nicht,
haben die mittlerweile ihren Einspieler World Premiere.
Vor allem, das Game hast du vorher schon Previews und sonst was überall in der GameStar am Ende fest gelesen.
Also quasi jetzt nicht die Quelle, die jetzt für absolute Leaks und Bleeding-Edge-Informationen bekannt ist.
Und dann kommt bei dem Microsoft World Premiere.
Und dann sagt man, Moment, man hat doch schon alles gesehen, wo ist das jetzt für eine schöne Weltpremiere?
Oder kurz Twitter schreiben.
Die Musik ist ein bisschen MonkaS, das ist der Endgegner aus Mario Galaxy.
Sag mal, warum kann mein iPhone Sony nicht Autocompleten?
Na gut, habe ich mir gerade beantwortet, weil es mein iPhone ist. Warum sollte das iPhone das können?
In der Playstation ist ein Ryzen drin, klar, natürlich.
Ich bin mir gar nicht sicher, ob die PS5-Hardware schon komplett klar ist, aber es ist ein Ryzen drin.
Es ist eine Art Ryzen, der wahrscheinlich nicht Ryzen heißen will, aber im Endeffekt ist da höchstwahrscheinlich ein Ryzen drin.
Ich würde sagen, wir müssen mal kurz gucken, ob es nicht schon bestätigt ist.
Aber es ist ein Ryzen drin und es ist eine AMD-Grafikkarte drin, also quasi CPU und Grafikkarte vom gleichen Hersteller.
Es ist eine super, dolle, mega, übertrieben krasse SSD drin.
Das weiß ich auch nur daher, weil wir uns die Präsentationen davon angeguckt haben.
Und bevor ich eingeschlafen bin... Wo ist das Stream gerade am Abgang?
Vodafone!
Jetzt heute nicht!
Ok, ich gehe direkt auf Twitter flamen.
Also ok, ok, wir geben ihm bis 45 Zeit. Bis 45 kriegen sie Zeit.
Ok, also Twitter. Nee, nee, nee, bis 45. Ich gebe ihm bis 45 Zeit. Bis 45 gebe ich ihm Zeit.
Wechsel lieber zur Telekom, das ist auch nicht der Weisheitsletzter. Telekom ist genau so ein Scheißladen.
Aus anderen Gründen. Aber zumindest ist die Technik halbwegs brauchbar im Vergleich zu Vodafone.
1060p Stream. Exzellente Idee. Die Musik passt auch richtig gut dazu, oder?
Na, gehts wieder? Hey, ich glaube es geht wieder.
Wechseln zu Unity Media. Exzellente Idee. Ja, scheint wieder zu funktionieren.
Es sind alle Provider kacke. Die Telekom ist auch kacke. Aber auf anderer Ebene.
Bei der Telekom funktioniert in der Regel wenigstens die Netzwerktechnik, also sprich das Wichtigste bei einem Provider, noch am besten.
Das Problem ist, dass die Telekom nicht die Geschwindigkeit bei mir hat und die Telekom anderweitig Spasten sind.
Zum Beispiel, weil sie mir irgendwelche Abmahnungen schicken für Anschlüsse, die überhaupt nicht mir gehören.
Das hab ich euch ja schon erzählt. Hab ich übrigens nie wieder was von gehört, ne?
Der Chat sagt, der einzige Provider, bei dem ich bisher noch von keiner einzigen seelen irgendwas Positives gehört hab, ist Pijur.
Was ist das denn? Pijur? Ist das was türkisches? Pjur. Oder was isländisches könnte es sein.
Was ist Pijur? Was ist Pijur? Pijur. Pjur. Telekolumbus.
Das sieht aus wie ein Kinderkanal, nicht wie ein Provider. Mehrere Tier 3 Provider.
Komm, ich guck mal. Wo kann man einen Verfügbarkeitscheck machen von Pijur? Oh, Verfügbarkeit prüfen.
Ach so, ich muss jetzt mal irgendeinen Fake eingeben. Mal gucken, was die in Frankfurt haben.
Die Gutloidstraße hat mehr als vier Hausnummern. Jetzt prüfen. Leider noch nicht verfügbar.
Ist ja toll, aber die Gutloidstraße hat trotzdem, glaub, 350 Hausnummern oder so. Die Musik ist huge.
Irgendwie ist das, ist das der Rechner gerade langsam? Schau ich mal her.
Ich muss mal kurz Prozess-Explorer aufmachen und gucken, was da irgendwie zu viel RAM frisst.
Oder frisst er überhaupt was, viel RAM oder viel Auslastung? Nö. Eigentlich gar nicht, alles gut.
Excellent. Pijur. Hab ich wirklich noch nie gehört. Noch nie.
Ok, Pijur. Gucken wir mal. Bewertung.
Von Unity Media? Unity Media gibt's doch nicht mal.
1,3 Sterne. Das ist aber wirklich schlecht.
Fuck, Alter. Was ist denn das?
Was macht denn Skyrim bei Best of Nintendo Music?
Ach stimmt, den Kram gibt's ja mittlerweile auch auf der Switch. Hab ich ja ganz vergessen.
Skyrim gibt's ja nur mittlerweile echt für alles.
Und Kopf. Worst Internet Provider ever. Worst Customer Service ever.
Ok, das ist schlecht.
Das ist so ein Anbieter. Den würde ich, da würde ich mir eigentlich fast schon einen Anschluss dafür holen.
Also einen zweiten Anschluss. Einfach nur, weil's lustig ist und man permanent lustigen Content erstellen könnte.
Da könnten wir im Stream, könnten wir bei Pijur anrufen und fragen, was denn los ist.
Ich könnte Videos machen, wo ich irgendwie messe, wie kaputt Pijur ist.
Einfach rein, weil's lustig ist, müsste man sich dafür schon einen Anschluss holen.
Pijur.
Ach du Scheiße. Oh. Berlin F. Hahn. Hein. Zwar damit alles prima. Ja, noch wahrscheinlich.
Pijur. Nee. Also ich muss ehrlich sagen, Leute, der Chat ist wirklich wieder heute sehr, sehr big brain,
von dem Anbieter hab ich noch nie was gehört.
Keine Ahnung, dass der überhaupt existiert hat bis eben.
Fake. Genau. Fake News.
Ja, genau. Wir waren ja bei den Hardware Specks von der PS5.
Full PS5 Specification.
Aber so wirklich eine ordentliche Übersicht ist das nicht.
Ziemlicher Mist.
Stimmt das, was hier steht? Ich kann mich da nämlich überhaupt nicht mehr dran erinnern.
War das ein 8 Kern oder ein 12 Kern? Ich glaube 8 Kerne stimmt.
War es nicht so, dass man 12 Kerne vermutet hat und es sind am Ende jetzt doch nur 8 gewesen?
Ich glaube schon.
Zumindest in Xbox und PS5 wieder ziemlich gleich auf, was Leistung angeht.
Sony macht hier richtig große Attacke mit ihrer SSD. Microsoft hat ein paar andere Sachen,
aber unterm Strich macht es da keinen großen Unterschied.
Die Xbox ist ein bisschen schneller, aber im Großen und Ganzen dürfte es für die Games jetzt nicht so viel ausmachen.
8 x Zen 2 gleich 16. Ach, jetzt verstehe ich es. Excellent, big brain. So sieht es aus.
How much FPS will PS5? Ist klar, das weiß Google natürlich.
Jaja, ist klar.
Ich kann auch einen dreifarbigen Bildschirm in 4K und 120 FPS anzeigen lassen, das ist kein Problem.
Dass es Spiele in 4K und 120 FPS auf der PS5 gibt, ist eher im Land eher anzusiedeln,
als dass das wirklich so der Fall sein wird.
Wir können uns freuen, wenn die meisten Games jetzt endgültig mal durchgängig 1080p 60 FPS sind.
Ja, CSGO, aber CSGO werden sie wohl nicht nochmal releasen für die PS5.
CSGO gab es ja mal für die Xbox und die PS4 glaubst du gar. War das noch 360?
Ich weiß es gar nicht mehr, aber das war total sinnlos.
Soll ich mal in der Chat gucken, falls ich was vergessen habe zu beantworten?
Die Xbox sagt 8K. Okay, ja, es ist ja ein Unterschied zwischen, was rein der Output,
also was die Hardware Spezifikationen der Display-Schnittstelle hergeben
und was Spiele im Endeffekt wirklich rendern, sind ja komplett zwei Paar Schuhe.
Schau dir mal Salt-Fiber an. Salt-Fiber klingt irgendwie schon ziemlich nach Flame.
Salt-Fiber. Bewertung.
Wenn es denn mal läuft, dann richtig gut. Oh, der hat auch exzellente Sterne, 1,3.
Salt-Mobile. Oh, Moment, warum kann ich hier meinen?
Ich kann eben ausschreiben.
Auswandern, Schweiz. Hatte ich jetzt eigentlich nicht vor.
Aber wenn die Leute hier weiter so am Rad drehen, dann mache ich es vielleicht irgendwann mal.
Die spinnen ja alle richtig rum aktuell.
Ja, aber zur Frage, was ich mir gerne für Hardware kaufen würde.
Tatsächlich, am liebsten würde ich mir den Ryzen 4950X kaufen, wenn der das verspricht,
was man jetzt erahnen kann, ohne 3080Ti.
Aber das dauert wohl noch mindestens bis Ende des Jahres.
Spektrum 8.
Oh, der Michael 50 Billioner morgen im Vorstellungsgespräch.
Bei was? Wie heißen die?
Spektrum 8.
Welche Seite? Die da?
Ok, können wir uns angucken. Aber gib nicht so viel drauf, was ich erzähle.
Im Endeffekt muss es ja zu dir passen.
Also, Spektrum. Die werden schon mal niemals fertig hier.
Wie lange das Event geht?
Naja, wenn man sich die letzten Sony Events anguckt, dann eine Stunde oder eineinhalb Stunden.
Unlimited. Als was bewirbst du dich denn da? Weil Jobs.
Das Webdesign ist schon mal nicht... Ja, ach komm, geht doch, geht doch.
Also, unsere Benefits. Ok, also schauen wir uns das mal an.
Unsere Benefits. Vertrauenszeit. Ok, das gibt es mittlerweile bei vielen.
Meinen die Kleidzeit oder meinen die Vertrauenszeit?
Vertrauenszeit würde heißen... Es wird nichts erfasst, aber es muss ja was erfasst werden.
Getränke? Das ist gut. Obst.
Oder wie der Schwabe sagt, Obst. Obst.
Ist auch nett. Ja, warum nicht?
Als Benefits nicht Vorteil, ja.
Ruhebereich. Das haben wir übrigens auch.
Habe ich euch glaube ich noch nicht erzählt, wir haben in der Firma auch einen Ruhebereich.
Da geht nie jemand hin.
Hauptsächlich wahrscheinlich, weil du ausstechen musst.
Aber der ist gar nicht schlecht. Das ist ein Ruhebereich, der hat komplett grüne Sofas.
Und es stehen links und rechts zwei Surface Hubs, wo Kaminfeuer drauf läuft.
Also man hätte jetzt ja auch wirklich echte Pflanzen hinstellen können, aber das war nicht genug.
Man lieber grüne Sofas und einen Surface Hub mit Kaminfeuer hingestellt.
Altersvorsorge, das ist schon mal nicht schlecht.
Wenn man da länger bleiben will, ist eine betriebliche Altersvorsorge nicht verkehrt.
Aber halt immer nur unter der Voraussetzung, dass eben der Arbeitgeber die Hälfte bezahlt.
Dann lohnt sich das.
Homeoffice, ungünstige Termine. Das ist auch schon mal gut, dass sie das hinschreiben.
Firmenwagen.
Ok, wenn man braucht. Warum nicht? Unfallversicherung.
Gute Verkehrsanbietung. Das ist tatsächlich ein Benefit, aber da können die ja wenig für.
Surface Hub für Kaminfeuer. Habt ihr zu viel Geld? Ja, wir haben viel zu viel Geld.
Ganzen Bankversicherungsläden haben zu viel Geld.
Surface, Surface Hub, diese Dinger hier.
Ähm, ne ne ne ne.
Ja, die da.
Die Teile, da haben wir jede Menge von.
Das juckt aber, das juckt die Firma, wo ich arbeite, nicht, dass es 10k kostet. Das ist denen vollkommen egal.
Was geht noch weiter? Spielzeug, Datscheibe, Kicker und Bilder. Ok, das braucht kein Mensch.
Man geht ja auf die Arbeit, um zu arbeiten.
Und um pünktlich heimzugehen, wenn man seine Arbeit erledigt hat.
Hunde geduldet. Ok, das wird mir persönlich auf den Keks gehen.
Aber es ist Geschmackssache. Das wäre gut noch schlecht jetzt.
Bei uns muss niemand ungewollt schwitzen. Klimaanlage.
Da hast du dann die Mädels, die sagen, oh nein, mir ist es zu kalt.
Da hast du ja andere, die sagen, oh ne, mir ist es jetzt zu warm.
Aber Klimaanlage ist ja sogar bei manchen Sachen Pflicht, wenn es da zu warm wird.
Wenn Wufi lieb ist.
Ok, ähm. Michael, habe ich dich gefragt, als was du dich da bewirbst?
Anwendungsentwickler. Ah, ok.
Chef-OP sage ich, denke ich mir auch.
Wer braucht Spielzeug? Ich gehe einfach lieber heim, wenn meine Arbeitszeit vorbei ist.
Anstatt, dass ich da eine Stunde rum sitze und was spiele.
Spiele gerade auch daheim, dann kann ich spielen, was ich will.
Letztens habe ich ein Video auf YouTube gesehen von irgendeiner Firma, die angepriesen hat.
Oder ein Video, was das Video gezeigt hat, so rum. Von irgendeiner Firma, die gesagt haben,
wir hatten einen Mario, wie sie haben einen Mario Kart Raum.
Da dachte ich mir aus, alter, was brauche ich denn Mario Kart Raum auf der Arbeit?
Will meine Arbeit machen, dann gehe ich heim, gut ist. Umfeld.
Der Arbeitsplatz sieht schon mal ganz gut aus hier.
Drei ordentliche Bildschirme. Ein bisschen zu offen, aber ich weiß nicht, was das für ein Laden ist.
Aber Arbeitsplatz Ausstattung sieht schon mal ganz gut aus.
Warum sind die Bilder eigentlich so furzklein?
Und was macht denn der Laden? Was macht der Laden überhaupt?
Was machen die denn? Was machen die?
About.
Neue Projekte, hoffentlich kein Webdesign.
Okay, ich habe keine Ahnung, das ist absolut nichts sagend.
Webshops. Okay, also mit Webdesign haben sie es wirklich beim besten Willen nicht so, ne?
Ich meine, wer hat dieses Menüdesign? Das ist ja absolut Zumutung.
Das ist Nekrodancer oder sowas, ne? Musik.
Ja, genau. Crypt of Nekrodancer.
Ohne Samzugpflicht, Michael, wer weiß.
Also mit Webdesign haben sie es auf jeden Fall schon mal nicht.
Machen wir mal Darkreader aus. Oh, dann wäre ich aber so geplättet.
Übrigens, ich habe nichts gesagt, den Darkreader muss ich echt ausmachen, also die können dafür gar nichts.
Wie sieht das Menü jetzt aus? Okay, das Menü ist auch nicht besser.
Naja, viel besser ist das Menü ehrlich gesagt auch nicht.
Michael, du hattest zur Schule Anzug an, willst du mich debaten?
Warum?
Musik.
Okay, aber mit Webdesign haben sie es trotzdem nicht so.
Mitarbeiter-Events, oje, MonkaS.
Ein mit unordentlicher Hose ist ja, ist da, das ist ja was anderes.
Aber komplett im Anzug würde ich nicht in die Schule gehen, aber jeder wieder macht, ja.
Neben der Weihnachtsfeier im Sommerfest haben wir auch noch diverse Teamabende, oje, oje.
Da würde ich gleich sagen, habe ich keinen Bock drauf.
Aber Michael, wenn das was für dich ist, was dir gefällt, da habe ich nichts gesagt, ja.
Ein erster Abend mit uns wird bereits in der Bewerbungsphase stattfinden.
Oh nein, oh Gott, hör auf.
Du musst an dem Kram teilnehmen und gut wetter machen, dass sie dich überhaupt einstellen oder was?
Oh nee.
Da hätte ich keinen Bock drauf.
Ey, aber manchmal, ja, manchmal kann, das muss jetzt nicht, du wirst nie was finden, wo 100%ig alles gut ist.
Genauso wenig, wie es kaum was gibt, wo 100%ig alles schlecht ist.
Vielleicht ist das auch so eine Sache, wo du einfach Augen zu und durch musst.
Oder du kannst sehen, wenn es eine wirklich gute Firma ist und man denen sagt, man hat Probleme mit Ansammlung von vielen Menschen,
dass das nichts mit den Leuten zu tun hat, dass du die irgendwie, dass du irgendwie die Leute abwerten willst oder so,
sondern du hast Probleme mit Anzahl, mit Events, wo viele Leute sind, dann sollte das eine gute Firma verstehen.
Martin sehe ich genauso, exakt meine Aussage, ich will da arbeiten, ich muss mit denen nicht unbedingt befreundet sein.
Ich muss noch nicht mal wirklich gut finden, was ein Laden macht.
Es hat seine Vorteile, aber muss nicht sein.
Im Endeffekt müssen, sollen sich einfach nur beide Seiten an den Arbeitsvertrag halten, also sprich, ich gehe dahin, erbringe meine Leistung, dafür wünsche ich meine Kohle.
Und das war's.
Bei uns ist demnächst auch wieder Sommerfest und bei uns haben sie jetzt, können sie ja wegen Corona kein Sommerfest machen.
Unser Sommerfest ist jetzt rein online.
Per Livestream.
Dort, wo ich arbeite.
Da kannst du mit Zoom, per Zoom, Alter.
Die haben einen offiziellen Livestream, da ist unser Netzwerkteam voll in Panik, weil so viel Traffic und so.
Und man kann, das wird moderiert, das ist, glaube ich, zweieinhalb Stunden Livestream oder so.
Und dabei gibt es dann Gewinnspiele, wo man mit Zoom teilnehmen kann und so was.
Ich werde das mal fünf Minuten einschalten zum Cringen und dann bin ich wieder weg.
Vielleicht auch gar nicht, je nachdem.
Eiskäuter war bei mir auch so.
Der einzige Grund, warum ich früher zu Weihnachtsfeiern hin bin, ist, weil es kostenloses Essen gab.
Ja.
Und noch einen anderen Grund, den ich euch noch nie erzählt habe, wo ich es voll verkackt habe.
Es gab, weiß ich noch, beim Provider, das kann ich jetzt ja erzählen, das kann ja eh keiner genau zuordnen.
Wo ich noch bei dem Provider gearbeitet habe, wo ich meine Ausbildung gemacht habe.
Aus die Baro habe ich das doch erzählt.
Dort, wo ich meine Ausbildung gemacht habe, da gab es auch eine mit Auszubildende.
Und in die war ich so ein bisschen verknallt, ja.
Und das war auch eine der Gründe, warum ich immer auf die Weihnachtsfeier gefahren bin.
Das war so das einzige Mal im Jahr, wo man die gesehen hat.
Und dann war es auch nicht so wirklich in der Firma, wo man den ganzen Tag arbeiten muss.
Und jetzt passt mal auf, der Max hat es extrem, extrem verschissen.
Eine Weihnachtsfeier, das dürfte wahrscheinlich sogar die letzte Weihnachtsfeier gewesen sein,
bevor wir fertig waren mit der Ausbildung.
Also da saß die auch bei mir am Tisch.
Und da sind irgendwie gerade mal kurzzeitig alle weg gewesen.
Und da hat die zu mir gesagt, sie wird jetzt gerne heimgehen,
ob ich sie nicht noch quasi zum Bahnhof bringen kann.
Und ich habe es nicht gecheckt.
Ich habe es nicht gecheckt.
Ich habe nicht nein gesagt.
Nee, nee, nee, nee, ich habe nicht nein gesagt.
Ich habe gesagt, ja klar, da sind wir losgegangen.
Und irgendwie haben das da noch ein paar andere mitgekriegt,
dass wir aufgebrochen sind.
Und. Also irgendwie zwei, drei andere Leute, auch noch ein paar andere Mädels da von der Firma.
Und die haben gesagt, sie müssen auch zum Bahnhof.
Sie gehen mit, sie gehen mit ihr zum Bahnhof.
Also insofern, ich muss nicht mit, so nach dem Motto.
Also da, ja gut, dann ist gut, dann gehe ich gleich.
Dann mache ich mich vom Acker.
Das war richtig bescheuert.
Ich habe es nicht gecheckt, Leute, ich war zu blöd für.
Ich war, ich war zu doof für.
Ja, Pains Jam.
Richtig Pains Jam.
Da habe ich, das habe ich nicht schnell genug.
Dabei war die Sache eigentlich.
Nee, ich war gar nicht mal so besoffen.
Ich war einfach doof.
Ich habe es nicht gecheckt.
Doch eigentlich habe ich es gecheckt.
Ja, aber so Sachen hat wahrscheinlich jeder was.
Ich hätte sagen müssen, ja klar, ich komme noch mit zum Bahnhof.
Und wenn die anderen dann weg gewesen wären,
dann hätte sich bestimmt irgendwas ergeben,
so nach dem Motto, ja hier dazu dauert noch eine Weile,
oder so nach dem Motto, ja ist ja noch,
ist ja eigentlich noch früh, ist ja noch Zeit oder irgendwas, ja.
Ich habe es verkackt.
Keine Nerven gehabt, vielleicht auch das, ja.
Aber einfach nicht gecheckt.
Das war, das ist so eine Sache, die ärgert mich heute noch.
Das ist so eine Sache, die ärgert mich heute noch,
dass ich nicht gecheckt habe, weil es beruhte,
es beruhte irgendwie auf Gegenseitigkeit, ja.
Also ich hatte schon den Eindruck,
dass nicht nur ich die ganz gut finde,
sondern umgedreht auch, also das hätte,
das hätte was werden können, ja.
Und außerdem genau Krypto Meister,
ansonsten hätte sie nicht gefragt,
warum sollte die irgendwie so einen random Dude aus Frankfurt fragen,
wenn man in einer anderen Stadt dann da zum Bahnhof gebracht
oder so dalbe knackt, ja.
Ah ja.
Tja.
Ja, Michael.
Sieht doch eigentlich ganz okay aus.
Bis auf die Team-Events.
Fachinformatik anwesend, dafür bewirbst du dich, glaube ich, ja.
Wann kommt denn die Mist des Wubblors?
Wenn ich mich, wenn ich weiter meine bisherige Linie,
was zwischenmenschliche Interaktionen angeht
und zwischenmenschliche Beziehungen verfolge
oder besser gesagt die nicht vorhandene,
dann wird das wahrscheinlich nie was.
Geh einfach wieder auf Firmenevents, ich hasse Firmenevents.
Was, Prämie habe ich nicht gelesen?
Wo steht was von Prämie?
Leistungsprämie.
Bei uns gibt es keine Leistungsprämie,
aber dafür investieren wir das Budget in ein mehrtägiges externes Team.
Okay, hätten sie lieber gar nichts schreiben sollen.
Wie viele Firmenevents machen die eigentlich?
Mitarbeiter-Events und Leistungsprämie-Firmenevents.
Hör ja gar nicht auf.
Der Chat ist gerade beschäftigt,
sich gegenseitig zu erzählen,
wie sehr sie sich schon verkackt haben.
Also das ist die Ausbildung wahrscheinlich,
wo du dich beworben hast, denke ich mal.
Das Grüne auf dem Blau sieht nicht wirklich gut aus.
Fließende Sprachkenntnisse in Deutsch.
Fachhochschulreif und höher, zuverlässig oder was?
Okay, bla, bla, bla, bla.
Blitzbewerbung.
Okay.
Bewerben wir uns mal. Nee, aber nicht.
PAP-Kentnisse.
CSS, JavaScript.
Hast du vielleicht noch...
Das verwendet man noch?
Cent-Framework, das hat man vor 1000 Jahren verwendet
in der Webentwicklung.
Vue.js Laravel, ja, das ist was, damit kann man was anfangen.
Aber Cent?
Referenzen.
Ich weiß, was wir hochladen, wartet mal.
Andere Sachen, die du gut beherrschst.
Face-Rollen.
Was?
Aha!
Exzellent.
Okay, alles klar.
Warum nicht?
C++-Flame, ne?
Was?
Michael, die wissen doch nicht, dass du das bist, Alter.
Das hat doch damit nichts zu tun.
Okay.
Bei denen kannst du, die machen echt einen guten Eindruck,
bis auf die Team-Events.
Team-Events suckt.
Ein Pui wurde direkt weitergeleitet, ja.
Nein, Michael, das glaube ich nicht, dass die meinst,
du bist ein Pui.
Nein, Michael, das glaube ich nicht,
dass die meinen Stream gucken.
Und wenn nicht, überleg dir mal.
Stell dir vor, die gucken wirklich meinen Stream
und es fällt auf dich zurück.
Dann ist das doch eher von Vorteil für dich.
Da habt ihr gemeinsames Gesprächsthema.
Da kannst du sagen, wie ihr guckt das auch.
Da kannst du sagen, Alter, was für ein Spaß.
Da hast du, eigentlich ist es sogar gut,
wenn die meinen Stream gucken.
So, was?
Hi, habe mir den Mikrotik,
was?
Routerboard plus 5...
Die Mikrotik-Bezeichnung, Alter.
Könntest du mal einen Mikrotik-Guide machen?
Nicht wirklich.
Das ist ein äußerst komplexes Thema,
Router OS.
Aber der Router ist echt gut.
Der ist wirklich richtig gut,
wenn du halt das brauchst, was der kann.
Also ein Fritzbox-Ersatz ist es nicht...
Warum ist auch Mikrotik mein?
Ein Adblock aus...
Also ein richtiger Fritzbox-Ersatz
ist es nicht.
Dafür ist es ein deutlich besserer Router
mit deutlich besserem Betriebssystem für
und Funktionen, was Routing angeht,
wie die Fritzbox.
Ja, der Name ist vielleicht
ein bisschen MonkaS, ja.
RB4011...
Aber es ist so,
die Sachen haben bei...
Die Sachen haben bei Mikrotik
eine gewisse Logik.
Das ist Routerboard...
Oh, Moment, ich hab mein Chat
irgendwie verschoben.
Routerboard 400i,
1 SFP-Plus-Port,
11 Gigabit-Ports,
wahrscheinlich, vermute ich mal.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5,
6, 7, 8, 9,
10,
ok, was auch immer.
11 Ports,
also in dem Fall ergibt die Mikrotik Benamung
auch nicht so wirklich Sinn, oder?
Oder sind es 5
SFP-... Nee.
Ok, nee.
Die Mikrotik Benamung gibt hier nicht wirklich Sinn.
Dass es einen Axis Point hat,
und was für einen Axis Point?
Ok, die
Mikrotik Benamung gibt meistens Sinn,
aber in dem Fall check ich sie zumindest nicht.
Aber der Router ist wirklich gut.
Hinten ist noch eine Konsole, vielleicht
ist es der, ja.
Ähm, wofür hast du
den denn gekauft?
Äh, wenn ich jetzt finde,
finde wer das gefragt hat.
Hat der auch einen DSL Modem? Nee.
Unter anderem hat er auch keinen DSL Modem,
hat keine Deckbasis Station.
Also einen Fritzbox-Ersatz ist es wie gesagt nicht.
Was für
einen Router hast du? Ich hab einen Hex
PoE.
Und eine Unity Media Connect Box
und noch eine Fritzbox.
Ähm, das ist eine gute
Frage hier.
Hast du schon mal,
wobei wir können uns die Fragen auch hier angucken,
dann seht ihr wenigstens welche, welche ich nehme.
Schul, also.
Hast du schon mal Schulprojekte
aufgeschoben und wenn ja, wie ging's aus?
Ich schieb fast alle Projekte, die ich hab
auf, weil ich total
faul bin.
Ich schieb fast alle auf. Und wie ging's
aus? Meistens ohne Probleme.
Also es ist bei mir auch so,
auch wenn ich auf der Arbeit irgendwas vorstellen
soll, sonst was bei mir. Ich schieb
alles irgendwie auf. Aber meistens geht's
ganz gut aus, weil ich dann
irgendwann, so kurz
bevor es wirklich ernst wird,
das spüre und
mich damit beschäftige.
Und mich dann aber auch auf nichts anderes
mehr konzentriere. Also zum
Beispiel, wir mussten vor zwei Wochen
mal wieder eine, eine, eine
Sache von uns vorstellen. Und wir
haben
am
Montag
morgen die Vorbereitung
für die Präsentation gemacht, um
für Montag 13 Uhr.
Hat wunderbar funktioniert. Dafür
haben wir auch zwei Stunden nichts anderes gemacht.
Bei anderen Sachen muss man natürlich ein bisschen
früher anfangen. Und ich kann euch
auch nur empfehlen, wenn ihr irgendwelche Sachen vorstellen
musst, übt das vorher mal
ein paar Mal. Es gibt
sagen wir mal, es gibt zwar Naturtalente,
die gut reden können, aber
gut reden können ist bei einem Vortrag
was, wo es um technische Sachen geht,
ist aber auch
nicht komplett alles.
Also man muss schon Ahnung haben,
wovon man redet. Und
damit man sich die Sachen besser merken kann,
ist es schon sinnvoll, den Vortrag
zwei oder drei Mal
runterzuspulen vorher.
Vielleicht auch mit ein, zwei
Zuhörern. Aber Leute, mit denen man gut
klar kommt, dann ist es nämlich einfacher.
Und dann kann man sich nämlich den Text
viel besser merken.
Der Garten.
Der Garten sieht
immer noch ziemlich genauso aus wie damals.
Bei der letzten Präsentation
war eigentlich eh voll verkehrte
Welt. Wir haben so gut wie nichts
Neues gemacht. Das Einzige,
was wir vorgestellt haben, ist,
zusätzlich zu dem, was
wir vorher vorgestellt haben,
dass wir was programmiert haben, was
Confluence abgleicht
mit Server-Informationen aus einer
Datenbank.
Und das haben wir vorgestellt, da waren sie
alle voll begeistert.
Und da haben wir uns so gefragt, ey, was machen sie erstmal,
wenn wir wirklich was gemacht haben?
Musstest du mal einen Vorteil in Englisch halten?
Ja.
Das war eher
Das war eher so.
Hehehehe
Ups
Ja,
I gamble null,
wie sagt man heutzutage?
Fühle ich total.
Ne, genau so würde ich das auch machen.
Genau so würde ich das auch machen. Ich lasse die Sachen
immer übelst lange schleifen.
Und wenn ich da so ein inneres Gefühl bekomme,
oh, jetzt wird es aber langsam ernst,
dann mach ich nichts anderes mehr.
Was soll beim PS5 Event gezeigt werden?
Das ist noch nicht so ganz klar.
Aber hoffentlich weitere Details
zur PS5 und vor allem was für Games
kommen.
Könntest du nochmal
deine Kameras Webcams zeigen, die du benutzt
mit Custom Firmware? Ja.
Eine ist mir jetzt aber verreckt.
Eine ist mir komplett verreckt.
Da ist die SD-Karte,
der SD-Kartenlaser kaputtgegangen.
Die hier.
Und, oh, die sind
viel zu teuer geworden. Warum sind die so teuer?
Davor hat die kleine,
die kleine, ach, das ist ein Zweierpack.
Okay.
Dann ist was anderes.
Also, ich habe fünf davon bestellt,
fünf davon bestellt.
Und aktuell in Benutzung habe
ich eine im Hof,
eine im Flur,
eine im Keller.
Muss mal kurz auf meine Kameras gucken,
dass ich nichts vergesse. Eine
in den Zimmer, wo sich die Katze immer
ablegt. Und
noch eine
am Hoftor, wobei das am
Hoftor eine Raspberry Pi Kamera ist.
So.
Das lohnt sich aber nicht wirklich.
Das lohnt sich nur, wenn man sich was bestellt,
wenn man sich eine ordentliche Menge bestellt,
weil man bezahlt bei Amazon.com,
wenn man diesen Versand nach Deutschland
machen lässt. Also sprich, die haben ja
mittlerweile eine richtig gute
Möglichkeit, Sachen nach Deutschland zu verschicken,
was auch viel schneller geht. Die verschicken das
meiste gar nicht wirklich
von Amazon.com, sondern irgendwo von hier.
Das kostet
aber 25 Euro Versand zusätzlich.
Das lohnt sich also nur, wenn man da ordentlich
was kauft.
Und die Custom-Firma ist die hier.
Äh.
Alter, die Musik, was los?
Das...
Jetzt übertreiben ist es aber.
Das ist die
Custom-Firma dafür.
Das können wir auf eine Micro SD-Karte machen.
Also preisleistungsmäßig ist es okay.
Wie gesagt, 20 Dollar, 20,
25 Dollar für eine Kamera,
die von den Funktionen her echt top ist.
Mit der Custom-Firma gibt es nichts zu sagen.
Es gibt aber bessere Sachen, die man sich kaufen kann,
wenn man wirklich eine funktionsfähige,
belastbare,
ausfallssichere Kamera haben will.
Möchtest du mein Heimnetzwerk sicher machen?
Gut, das kannst du
mit dem Mikrotik-Router
schon machen.
Aber irgendwelche Advanced-Security-
Features kann der nicht.
Der hat halt eine ganz normale IP-Firewall drin.
Aber irgendwelche Inspection
oder
Proxies,
die irgendwelche Protokolle verstehen
und On-the-Fly-Viren erkennen können.
Sowas hat der nicht.
Der Mikrotik-Router hat ein ganz stinknormales,
ganz stinknormale IP-Firewall.
Dafür kann er im Gegensatz zur Fritz-Box
halt alles andere, was gute Router können.
Oder auch was gute Switches können.
Zum Beispiel in VLANs.
Und auch ziemlich schnell intern routen.
Cheat95,
das funktioniert folgendermaßen.
Man flasht einen Bootloader.
Einen neuen Bootloader.
Und der bootet
von der SD-Karte,
wenn eine SD-Karte drin ist.
Wenn keine SD-Karte drin ist,
bootet er die Stock-Firmware
vor dem Hersteller.
Also das heißt, man kann
die Kamera immer verwenden,
wie man will.
Kennst du eine gute Alternative
zu WLAN oder DLAN?
Ja, Kabel.
Was ist hier los gerade?
Unser Router ist ein Stockwerk tiefer
und wir haben eine fette Stahlbetonte.
Oh, das ist schlecht.
Ähm...
Es gibt noch die Option,
wenn es...
Du kannst Richtung...
Also WLAN kannst du
mit so ein bisschen...
Den passenden...
Wie heißt denn das?
Mit den passenden Antennen, die besonders gut
in eine Richtung abstrahlen,
kannst du es mal probieren.
DLAN ist jetzt nicht so mein Fall.
Ansonsten...
Ja, bohren.
Das ist aber auch
schwierig, ja.
Hast du vielleicht was
anderes da liegen?
Hast du vielleicht noch alte Kupferkabel
oder irgendwas von einem Telefonanschluss
da liegen? Dann kann man was machen.
Also wenn du paar Kabel hast,
mindestens zwei. Wenn du noch mindestens
zwei Kabel hast,
die dazwischen liegen, gibt es Alternativen, ja.
Äh, die Leute auf Github
sind auch immer dreister.
Ok, das ist ein Build, das muss ich...
Kann ich nicht im Stream aufbauen, da muss ich erstmal vorher gucken,
was das ist.
Hä? Verstehe ich nicht.
Ach, die schreiben dich an, weil du
ein Repo gestarrt hast. Ja, das ist
natürlich bescheuert.
Die sollen immer die...
einem auf den Sack gehen.
Huge-Emote-Einblendung,
ah ja, da werden wir uns wieder auslassen gleich.
Aber wie gesagt, hat kein DSL-Modem.
Hatten wir schon, hatten wir schon.
Was hindert dich jetzt daran, dich einfach nochmal
bei ihr zu melden? Ich wüsste noch nicht mal wo.
Mal ganz davon abgesehen,
das ist über zehn Jahre her.
Wahrscheinlich ist die mittlerweile alt
und hässlich, so wie ich.
Wie war dein Fazit zu Bitborn gestern?
Konnte leider irgendwann nicht mehr weiter gucken.
Ich fand's ganz gut.
Bullshit-Bingo, ich hab keinen Bullshit-Bingo dafür.
Und ich kann auch keins erstellen, weil ich absolut keine Ahnung habe,
was die ankündigen werden.
Wie war dein Fazit?
Ja, genau, also ich fand's gut.
Ich werde es nicht verwenden,
aber für jemand, der gerade auch die ganze
Smartphone-App-Geschichte braucht
und die als Autocomplete auf Android
und was man einfach
zünden kann, ist das echt nicht verkehrt.
Zur Sicherheit kann ich halt gar nichts sagen.
Hab ich mich nicht mit beschäftigt.
Das ist auch unter anderem der Grund, warum ich nach wie vor KeyPass verwende.
Weil ich KeyPass einfach traue, dass es funktioniert.
Geh auf Tinder und installier Tinder und geh auf ein paar Events.
Alles klar.
Tinder ist, glaube ich, eines der letzten Sachen, die ich mir installiere.
Und auf Events zu irgendwelchen Leuten gehen erst recht nicht.
Die sagen, save, dass es die beste Playstation ist, die jemals gemacht wurde.
Ja, das stimmt.
Kannst du bei uns anfangen?
Ich habe die Seite nicht angeguckt, weil ich was suche,
sondern weil mich jemand aus dem Chat gefragt hat,
weil ich dazu sage.
Aber ich guck's mir auch mal an. Was ist das?
Riegel Laser Measurement Systems.
Die Webseite ist optimiert für den Microsoft Internet Explorer oder so.
Aber eigentlich mag ich so Webseiten prinzipiell, die leichtgewichtig sind.
Man muss ja nicht heutzutage alles mit JavaScript machen,
nur weil es mit JavaScript geht.
Also, was wollten ihr haben?
Programmierung in JavaScript und PHP.
Mac, PC, Mac, Smartphone, Software, Dokument.
Excellent.
Wenigstens eine Sache, mit der ich mich auskenne.
Also, Software Dokumentation ist ja einfach.
Software Dokumentation kann jeder, der gut programmieren kann.
Man muss einfach so programmieren, dass es jeder versteht.
Und dann braucht man keine Dokumentation.
Da sind wir uns ja alle einig, oder?
Ja.
Und wenn man das Ganze dann noch eingecheckt hat in ordentliche Versionsverwaltung,
dann ist das quasi besser als jede Dokumentation.
Software Support.
Okay, Abschluss.
HTL Abschluss.
Was ist denn HTL?
Hohe Technische Lernabschluss.
Nee.
HTL.
Ich weiß nicht, was das ist.
Sehr gute Programmierkenntnisse.
JavaScript, PHP.
Okay, JavaScript meinetwegen, PHP geht so.
JQuery.
Okay.
Jason, Leaflet.
Ah, Leaflet.
Hey, die zwei Sachen kann ich wirklich.
Weil, wie gesagt, ich hab doch mit meinem einen Kollegen da dieses...
Die Web-Anwendung gebastelt, wo man sich Routen berechnen lassen kann.
Das ist mit Leaflet und Google Maps APIs.
Irgendwas aus Österreich.
Höhere technische Lehranstalt.
Okay.
Erfahrung in der GUI-Umsetzung.
Erfahrung, Entwicklung, Node-Anwendung.
3D-Visualisierung.
Ach, du Scheiß.
Dass das ein Web-Entwickler auch um GL und Shader gedönst kann.
Also, das ist, glaube ich, nicht so verbreitet.
Erfahrung im Umgang mit Softwareverwaltungssystemen.
Gibt ja wenigstens eine Sache, von der ich richtig Ahnung habe.
Das ist ein Stellangebot, würde ich sagen.
Lernbereitschaft.
Da könnte ich auf Österreich auswandern, das wäre doch auch nicht schlecht.
Aber ich weiß nicht, ob es da besser ist.
Ich glaube, die haben genauso viel gestörte Leute wie wir.
Das einzige deutschsprachige Land, wo ich glaube, die haben nicht so viel gestörte Leute, ist die Schweiz.
Aber das kann täuschen, weil ich noch nie in der Schweiz war.
Ach so, das Geld habe ich jetzt gar nicht nachgeguckt.
Wie viel gibt es denn?
Delphi?
Monkeys?
Wow!
Das ist aber nicht viel.
Nee, das ist aber nicht viel.
Ich meine, das sind...
Mal 12, ich weiß nicht, wie viel Monatsgeld das...
Was?
Also ganz ehrlich Leute, das kann doch nicht euer Ernst sein.
Und selbst mal 14 ist es nicht viel.
Mein WTF?
Also für 30k, da kannst du ja bei der hessischen Polizei anfangen und kriegst mehr Geld.
Wie viel verdient man mit Hartz IV so?
Nee, die meinen tatsächlich...
Also sprich, davon musst du noch Steuern bezahlen.
Gut, ich weiß nicht, wie es mit Steuern in Österreich aussieht.
Also wenn Österreich keine Steuern hat, dann mag das gehen.
Aber wenn Österreich wahrscheinlich auch recht hohe Steuern hat, dann...
Ja.
Also so eine 2-3 Tage Woche, wenn man plus ein Land mit wenig Steuern, dann wird das ja irgendwie noch durchgehen.
Aber ansonsten ist wirklich sehr wenig.
Ja.
Micharo sagt, wir haben Steuern bis zum Umfallen, aber wahrscheinlich nicht so viel wie wir.
Naja, Michael 50.000, wenn du ausgelernt hast und ein bisschen Erfahrung hast.
Komm, es kommt auf die Region an.
Kommt auf die Region an, aber...
Sag mal, in Frankfurt, in Frankfurt, wir reden erstmal nur von Frankfurt, ja?
In Frankfurt würde ich auch nach der Ausbildung nicht unter 40.000 im Jahr anfangen.
Vorausgesetzt, du kannst ein bisschen was.
Also wenn du eine fachinformatische Ausbildung gemacht hast, würde ich nicht unter 40.000 anfangen in Frankfurt.
Jetzt einfach so mal aus dem Bauch raus gesagt, ich bin da nicht der beste Quelle für, weil wie gesagt,
ich war bisher in 15 Jahren bei zwei Arbeitgebern in dem Beruf.
Also da habe ich jetzt nicht so viele Erfahrungen.
Deswegen ist es wichtig, Leute, dass man was kann.
Wenn man was kann, was die Leute haben wollen, wenn man nicht die Sachen kann,
die der 0-15-Typ kann und die einfach sind, dann ist das, dann geht das auch.
Wenn ihr natürlich nur Druckerpatronen wechseln könnt, übertrieben gesagt,
dann gibt es halt 30.000 andere, die das können.
Oder ein bisschen Windows, Windows-AD rumklicken, das kann auch jeder.
Kennt ihr euch in irgendeinem Cloud-Bereich ganz gut aus oder irgendwelche Linux-Hosting-Geschichten
oder Programmiersprachen, sonst was, was gerade angesagt ist.
Kubernetes-Sachen auch, die gerade angesagt sind.
Wenn man sich mit irgendwas auskennt, was nicht jeder da hergelaufene Feld,
Wald und Wiesen-Physikern und davon dann auch noch ein bisschen Ahnung hat,
dass man damit was anfangen kann, dann kann man auch ordentlich Kohle kriegen.
Gut, CCNA ist so was, was fast jeder hat.
Martin, CCNA haben wirklich viele.
Natürlich gibt es mehr, die es nicht haben, als die, die es haben,
aber im Umfeld, wo es zählen könnte, also sprich irgendwo bei Netzwerk-Technik-Sachen,
da wird entweder CCNA belächelt oder eins juckt keinen, das man ihnen hat.
CCNA ist die Einsteiger-Cisco-Zertifizierung.
Heißt, glaube ich, Cisco...
Warte mal, Cisco Network Associate?
Was heißt denn CCNA?
Cisco Certified Network Associate.
Ah ja, exzellent.
Das habe ich auch mal gemacht, aber ich habe nie die Prüfung gemacht.
Was sagst du zur Sophos-Firewall?
Habe ich keine Erfahrung mit.
Was sagt eigentlich der Sony-Stream?
Geht da schon irgendwas?
Playstation ist Streaming?
Der YouTube-Stream ist weiter, habt ihr das gesehen?
Wir gucken YouTube.
30 Minuten noch.
Hast du das mit Battlefield 3 mitbekommen?
Ja, ich habe auch schon gesagt, dass ich persönlich bescheuert finde,
ich brauche kein, ich brauche kein Battlefield 3 Remastered.
Battlefield 3 sieht noch so gut aus und ist immer noch so frisch,
dass man da kein Remastered braucht.
Ich glaube, sie machen das nur, um die Zeit zu Battlefield 6 zu überbrücken,
weil sie mit Battlefield 5 verkackt haben.
Bobble sagt, habe gerade mega Probleme mit dem GastwLAN beim DHCP kleint wird.
Die Einstellung rot, keine Ahnung, was das rot bedeutet.
Meinst du, im Router OS Web Interface, rot bedeutet in der Regel...
Ne, grau bedeutet, dass es deaktiviert ist.
Was rot bei DHCP bedeutet, weiß ich jetzt auch gerade nicht.
Aber rot ist immer schlecht, ja, das stimmt.
Gucken wir uns noch ein paar weitere Questions an.
Ja, ich weiß, aber ich habe keine Ahnung, was rot bei DHCP im Router OS bedeutet aus dem Kopf.
Vielleicht, dass er, doch, wahrscheinlich, dass er das DHCP irgendwie nicht starten kann oder so.
Das sagen sie auf jeden Fall.
Hatten wir alles schon, hatten wir auch schon.
Warum eigentlich die neueste Playstation anschaffen, wenn die PCs gut gebaut besser sind?
Na ja, wegen den Spielen, die es auf der Playstation gibt.
Das ist ja der einzige Grund für eine Konsole.
Weil es auf der Konsole Spiele gibt, die es auf dem PC nicht gibt.
Und wenn man die spielen will, braucht man eine Konsole.
Alle anderen Argumente zählen kaum noch.
Ja, also ich lasse mir gefallen, wie gesagt, Exklusivspiele.
Auch wenn man sagt, ja, ich bin so ein Kacknoob und will halt eine einfache Bedienung haben.
Dann ist es auf einer Konsole immer noch angenehmer als auf dem PC.
Vor allem, weil man halt nichts rumstellen kann großartig.
Dementsprechend fängt man auch gar nicht an.
Die Musik hier wieder.
Hast du das 10 Jahre in Scope 21 gesehen, der Kabum wird erwähnt?
Nee, habe ich nicht, habe ich nicht gesehen.
Ich gehe mal davon aus, dass ich nicht erwähnt werde.
Sonst, sonst hätte ich es wahrscheinlich geschrieben.
So, Pifa, nee, nee, nee.
Hast du mitbekommen, dass Anonymos wurde von Ukei diese Woche gehackt?
Nee, habe ich nicht mitgekriegt.
Echt jetzt?
Hacker sind was?
Alter, die Gole im Seit ist teilweise echt eklig.
Temptocell Router.
Sorry, das ist Router.
Ja, habe ich.
Ist auch schon fertig, habe auch schon ein paar Runden gespielt.
Es gibt einen Trick, den hat einer auf Twitter geschrieben, den zeige ich euch mal.
Und der hat wirklich funktioniert.
Also ich habe mich ja heute darüber lustig gemacht, wie gut der Download funktioniert im Battle.net von Warzone.
Und da hat einer drunter geschrieben, Region auf Asien stellen, warten bis der Download wieder startet,
pausieren bei der Einstellung, Download Geschwindigkeit auf 300 setzen, Download fortsetzen,
dann auf Einstellung ohne pausieren und Download Speed wieder auf Null setzen.
Klingt, klingt bescheuert, aber es funktioniert.
Bei mir hat es funktioniert, allerdings geht das dann bloß 10 Minuten und dann muss man es wieder machen.
Nach 10 Minuten muss man das ganze wieder machen, allerdings Region umstellen nicht, weil
es könnte aber sein, dass Europa mittlerweile geht, weil die meisten geladen haben.
Aber bei mir hat es funktioniert.
Was ist das für Musik?
Telecom Racing, das könnte man Nachfolger kriegen.
Was soll ich mal angucken?
Eazi Unity Media, was?
Was ist das?
Ja, habe ich gesehen, dass es auch kacke läuft habe, kann ich mich noch dran erinnern.
Die Big Brain Frage, würdest du auf Route Server noch eine externe Firewall installieren oder denkst du,
für den einfachen Cloudbetrieb reicht fail to ban IP Tables?
IP Tables reicht für alles.
Machst einfach alles dicht, bis auf den Port, wo du von außen deine Sache ansprichst.
Fail to ban kann auch nicht schaden.
Ich empfehle immer noch, wenn du irgendwas laufen lassen willst, was funktioniert nicht.
Wenn du irgendwas laufen lassen willst, was von außen erreichbar ist, mach den Reverse Proxy davor.
Am besten noch mit Basic Orbs, da kannst du nur drauf zugreifen.
Das ist auch halbwegs abgesichert.
Ich meine, das ist nicht so das Basic Orbs jetzt die absolute Big Brain Geschichte wäre.
Aber Firewall, alles zumachen, IP Tables, alles blocken, außer den Port, wo ein Reverse Proxy drauf läuft.
Und dann ist gut.
Was für eine Internetgeschwindigkeit braucht man so für vier Leute?
Das kommt auf die Leute an.
Ich sage mal, so aus dem Bauchhaus unter 50 MBit musst du auf gar keinen Fall anfangen.
Weil ansonsten hast du ja schon Probleme, wenn einer YouTube guckt, einer Netflix, so nach dem Motto.
Ja, am besten so schnell wie geht.
50 ist eigentlich zu wenig, wenn alle das Internet ordentlich verwenden.
Dann sollten es wahrscheinlich eher schon Richtung 200 sein.
Besser 400 oder vielleicht...
Also bei vier Leuten für eine WG wird schon schnellste nehmen, was ich kriegen kann.
Aber es kommt auf die Leute an.
Denkst du mit Bioinformatik kann man was reisen?
Ja, ein ehemaliger Azubi von mir, oder von uns, wie man es nennen mag.
Der auch noch eine Weile danach bei uns gearbeitet hat, mit dem ich mich ganz gut verstanden habe.
Von dem weiß ich, der hat Bioinformatik studiert.
Der ist bei uns weg, hat angefangen, Bioinformatik zu studieren.
Und der war da voll begeistert.
Ich weiß nicht, was er jetzt macht, aber ich hoffe mal, dass das gut läuft bei ihm.
Du darfst dir wünschen, du darfst dir alles.
Ja, das genau, wer Modern Warfare gekauft hat, sollte mit dem Download bevorzugt werden wie Free2Play.
Ganz ehrlich, fände ich sogar ganz gut.
Nee, PC lustig, habe ich nicht.
Der Livestream auf Twitch ist besser als auf YouTube. Warum? Warum?
Ach so, die Qualität. Ist das so?
Wow, guckt euch das mal an. Alter.
Wir werden gucken, welcher Livestream weniger verzögert ist, und dann machen wir das.
Video Stats.
Also, was haben wir hier für eine Playback-Rate? Naja, gut, es passiert ja nichts.
Ein Embed und hier haben wir Stats.
Was? Nee.
Ich habe eine Idee, wisst ihr was wir machen? Wir machen es im VLC.
Das ist wirklich der Big Brain Move.
Geht nicht. Warum nicht?
Stream. Stream Link.
Stream Link? War Stream Link nicht dieses... Ah, excellent.
Stream Link.
Äh, wie hat man Stream Link überhaupt noch mal gestartet?
Stream Link best? Wie ging das noch mal?
Excellent.
Aber der Stream sah kacke aus.
Der Stream sah pixellig ohne Ende aus. Hier wird es da viel besser.
Es sieht hier viel besser aus als im VLC.
Leute, eine Viertelstunde geht es los. Twitch-Chat ist komplett am Eskalieren.
Keck. Wie? Ah, ich bin hier gar nicht eingeloggt.
Haben die Custom Emotes? Weiß man nicht.
Vergleichen wir es jetzt mal. Wir gucken jetzt welcher Stream aktueller ist.
Welcher Stream ist besser?
Hier hat es sich gerade neu aufgebaut. Der YouTube Stream ist jetzt schneller.
Ich muss den Chat... Kann ich den Chat nicht ausblenden?
Chat out.
Ich weiß nicht welcher Stream schneller ist.
Das ist absolut unmöglich. Wir gucken welcher schneller ist und dann nehmen wir den.
Qualitativ sehe ich keinen Unterschied.
Erhöhe mal die Geschwindigkeit beim YouTube Stream. So kommt man weiter nach vorne als live.
Jetzt schalten wir wieder zurück.
Will er gar nicht zurückspulen.
Wir sehen ja welcher Stream schneller ist. Sehen wir relativ gut gleich.
Spätestens wenn es los geht sehen wir welcher Stream schneller ist.
Schwier zu sagen oder?
Schwier zu sagen was davon schneller ist.
Das ist eine Schleife. Das könnte einfach eine komplette Schleife weiter vorne sein.
Es war kurz Black Screen. Twitch hatte den zuerst.
Wie gesagt, Bitrates erkenne ich leider nicht so richtig.
Aber das Audio auf Twitch ist besser mit FFZ Plugin.
Wenn alles nichts hilft, gucken wir es uns auf Mixer an.
Also was haben wir hier?
Sechs Ampets. Das ist ziemlich gut.
Für so Zeug was die haben.
Und hier erkennt man es halt nicht richtig.
Hier erkenne ich die Bitrate nicht. Wo ist hier die Bitrate?
Wir gucken es gleich auf TikTok.
Was ist hier die Bitrate? Connection Speed? Nee.
Bitrate müsste immer ein bisschen schwanken.
Er müsste nicht, aber meistens schwankt es ein bisschen.
Ich glaube nicht, dass Connection Speed die Bitrate vom Video ist.
Wir sehen es gleich.
Der Youtube Stream hat eine Variable Bitrate, aber ich sehe sie nicht.
Und jetzt kommt noch mehr der Vergleich. Wie sieht es mit VLC aus?
Wer ist schneller?
Wer ist schneller Leute?
Mehr Sony können wir nicht aufhaben.
Du streamst schon über zehn Monate. Ich stream schon seit zwei Jahren oder so.
Wir gucken mal die Bitrate vom VLC. Die ist nicht so gut.
Ach du Scheiße. Input Bitrate ist ja komplett RIP.
Die Bitrate vom VLC sieht reudig aus.
Warum ist die Bitrate vom VLC so schlecht?
Die Bitrate vom VLC Südl ist mies. Guckt euch das mal an.
Welcher Streamer die bessere Qualität hat, erkenne ich nicht.
Aber wir können Trick 17 machen. Wir machen jetzt einfach Stream Link für Twitch auf.
Dann gucken wir uns den Star an.
Wir gucken wahrscheinlich auch Twitch. Oh guckt mal. Twitch in VLC sieht ziemlich gut aus.
Was ist hier schneller?
Wir machen mal die Sony Musik an.
Stimmt. YouTube sieht kacke aus, weil es AVP9 ist.
Ich denke auch, dass wir Twitch gucken werden.
Gucken wir uns mal hier Bitrate an.
8 Minuten. Mehr Playstation Stream können wir nicht aufhaben.
Schauen wir auf die Lautstärke. Sieht ganz gut aus.
Das müsste hier viel besser sein, dank dem FFZ-Audio-Kompressor.
Ich finde gerade bei Streams mit Sprache und sowas ist der FFZ-Kompressor ganz praktisch.
Da hören sich die Sachen gleichmäßiger und teilweise sogar lauter an.
Ohne lauter zu sein.
Hier herrscht Expertise. Exzellent.
Ich muss mal gucken, ob Teams nicht wieder meine Mikrofon-Lautstärke umgestellt hat.
Gut, dann werde ich mal so einstellen, dass es für mich angenehm ist von der Lautstärke.
Und dann mache ich hier hoch.
Schauen wir mal, müssen wir anfangen zu schwätzen.
Du nutzt privat Teams. Nee, privat würde ich kein Teams verwenden. Ich bin doch nicht lebensmüde.
Wo kann man den Kompressor einschalten? Du musst einfach FFZ installieren hier.
Da ist er standardmäßig dabei und du musst ihn, ich glaube, ausschalten kannst ihn.
Exzellent.
Es wäre praktisch, wenn die eine Uhrzeit mit Sekunden einblenden würden, dass man die Streams besser sinken kann.
Also was es sinken, gucken kann, was man sich auf schneller ist.
Teams kosten, was ich glaube, man kann sich immer noch kostenlos registrieren.
Aber ich bin ja nicht lebensmüde für eine Teams freiwillig privat.
Teams.
Countdown wäre gut. Ja, schauen wir mal, da kommt bestimmt gleich ein Countdown oder sowas.
Ich würde sagen, so gucken wir uns das an, oder?
Das haben wir doch jetzt perfekt, perfekt gesynkt in der Mitte.
Emote in der Mitte.
Stream in der Mitte. Tripple Stream.
Exzellent, genau, wahrlich exzellent.
Muss aber noch in den Streamtitel, ich habe im Streamtitel Sony Event stehen, oder?
Müsste eigentlich drin stehen.
Ach, dreimal. Tripple Sony Event Stream.
So ist es am besten.
323 Viewer, huge. Prohorn, Twitch Prime, Dankeschön, zwei Monate.
Exzellent Subscription.
Massive Chat IQ Erhöhung.
Ich glaube, die meisten.
Ich glaube, die meisten Zuschauer, die ich mal hatte, jetzt mal von irgendwelchen Hosts ausgenommen,
waren mal bei einem Apple Event 800 oder 750 oder sowas.
Muss ich dann sogar ein paar beschwert haben, dass ich Apple geflamet habe.
Also richtig Apple Fanboys am Start.
Oh, das ist heute auch so, ey.
Playstation Fanboys sind die schlimmsten.
Robinson, Stufe eins, Dankeschön, huge Subscription.
Verdrückt mich übrigens, ich will gar nicht MonkaS sagen.
Ich will eigentlich Subscriber sagen, aber der Knopf ist fast nebeneinander.
Nice.
Heute wird nicht gehatet.
Heute wird einfach gesagt, was ich dazu denke.
Und ich bin da recht neutral.
Wo kam zuerst Stay Tuned Leute?
Wo kam zuerst Stay Tuned?
Ach ja, Leute, soll ich den Chat ausblenden?
Ich blende den Chat aus.
Wir machen den Chat weg.
Chat deleted.
Ich glaube, die neue Playstation läuft bestimmt auf.
Die Playstation läuft auf BSD.
Ne, geht doch alles.
Das ist jetzt kein Chebat.
Das macht die Playstation schon, glaube ich, seit der PS2.
Weil nur 48 FPS.
Naja, der offizielle Stream ist in 30 FPS.
Immer noch schneller als der offizielle Stream.
Oh, ach ne.
Ich glaube, also der YouTube Stream ist ewig hinten dran, wenn ich das gerade richtig gesehen habe.
Der Twitch Steam war zuerst, danach kommt VLC oder auch nicht, das ist schwer zu sagen.
Ah ne, wir machen heute keinen Bullshit Bingo, passt schon.
Stay Tuned war zuerst bei YouTube, okay.
Aber man hat es überhaupt nicht erkannt, den Playstation, den Twitch Stream.
Wir nehmen das, was die beste Quali ist, ja, Twitch und VLC.
YouTube ist ja, ich habe alles Maximum Quali.
Leute, es geht los jetzt. 22 Uhr.
Okay.
Welcher Stream wird es?
Jetzt werden auch Wetten angenommen.
Welcher Stream wird es? Welchen gucken wir uns an? Wo geht es zuerst los?
TikTok, ja, TikTok glaube ich auch.
Die Musik.
Soll ich mal gucken, ob es im Internet Explorer läuft, da ist bestimmt noch schneller.
Wir sind sowas von Tuned.
Jetzt, jetzt.
Okay, Twitch ist am schnellsten.
Excellent.
Ihr müsst mir gleich sagen, ob die Lautstärke passt.
Ich mache mal volle Pulle, ich mache volle Pulle Lautstärke.
Und dann müsst ihr mir sagen, ob es passt.
Ob zu laut, zu leise, zu sonst was.
Scheint zu passen.
Ich verschiebe mal meine Bildchen kurz ein bisschen auf die Seite.
Okay, wir feiern uns erstmal ein bisschen selbst.
Ein neues Little Big Planet, das wäre doch was.
Boi.
Final Fantasy Remake, Loll.
Das wäre dem Leben nichts.
Was kommt jetzt?
GTA 5 auch für die Plays?
Oh nee, oder?
Warum ist es PS4?
Da oben steht PS4.
Aber wenn sie GTA zeigen, hätten sie PS3 zeigen müssen, weil das kam ursprünglich auf der PS3.
Aha.
Zumindest wissen wir jetzt, dass die Lautstärke gut passt.
Expanded and Enhanced.
Sag ich doch, das ist eine Ankündigung für die PS5.
Okay, der 5 für die PS5, das gibt es jetzt für die PS3, für die PS4 und für die PS5.
Oh, okay, ich hab nichts gesagt, es gibt nichts, das ist kostenlos.
Ich hab nichts gesagt, das ist kostenlos, das ist okay, das ist in Ordnung.
GTA Cache, Moment.
Jetzt ist sogar schon Konsolen, Kauf, Pay to Win.
Und was hat man davon, wenn es jeder kriegt, egal.
Jetzt, jetzt hier.
Also eins muss man sagen, ihr Logo animieren können sie gut.
Das machen sie ja schon seit 30 Minuten.
Thrillend.
Leute, Skyrim?
Skyrim, PS5?
Skyrim muss auf aller Plattform.
Okay, jetzt, jetzt geht's los.
A hero is just someone who doesn't give up.
Your dad said that.
He was right.
Now it's your turn.
Spider-Man?
Nee, keine Ahnung.
Das würde zu Sony passen.
Spoda, Spodas.
Ja, also Spoda-Man.
Ist das der gleiche Spider-Man wie aus dem Animated Film?
Ja, anscheinend, ja.
Ah, Gran Turismo.
Gran Turismo juckt mich überhaupt nicht.
Okay, Autorennspiel.
Okay.
Ja.
Gibt bestimmt genug, denen das gefällt, aber Gran Turismo, genauso wie Forza ist nicht
mein Genre.
Mein Genre ist es nicht, nicht mein Genre.
Wetter.
Das sah cool aus, muss man ihn lassen.
Also mal, der Auto, ich geh um mich gar nicht.
Sieben.
Sieben sind die schon.
Ich hab noch nicht eins davon gespielt.
Sarah.
Oh, Campaign Mode.
Sarah hat schon so eine coole, coole Tuning-Mütze auf.
Auch Schröder ist dabei.
Da kann nichts passieren, wenn Schröder dabei ist.
Und Leitner auch.
Leute, wer kennt sich mit Rennspielen aus?
Gibt's die Leute echt?
Gibt's die?
Ist das, ist das, ist das Lizenz?
Ist das Lizenz oder sind das Random-Namen?
Ich hab, ich hab keinen blassen Schimmer.
Random.
Wie, wie Lehmann ist der Bruder von Jens Lehmann?
Ah, verstehe.
Random.
Also wenn das Xbox-Namen wären, dann würde der hier schon XXQuickscope360 heißen.
Okay, das war Resident Sleeper.
Next.
Was kommt denn jetzt?
Okay.
Okay, der Chat flippt aus.
Kann ich nicht mitreden, ich hab die Serie nicht gespielt.
Dankeschön Homer.
0818.
Aber es sieht sehr abwechslungsreich aus.
Was da vorne am Ende im Game sein wird, dann mal gucken.
Was ist denn das, ist das eher Jump and Run?
Oder was darf ich mir da drunter vorstellen, Chat?
Okay.
Too late.
Kill Ratchet.
Ah, okay.
Ah, nee.
Okay, es soll zumindest den Anschein erwecken, als wäre es in-Game.
Es ist wahrscheinlich auch in-Game.
Aber es ist halt wieder nur ein kleiner Ausschnitt, der einfach jetzt besonders gut das Ganze darstellen soll.
Also, was am Ende rauskommt, muss ich mal zeigen.
Aber ich hab absolut keine Erwartungen sonst viel zu dem Game, ich hab keinen Plan, nie gespielt.
Was passiert da überhaupt gerade?
Ja, eins muss man sagen, mehr Gameplay als die letzten Male zeigen sie tatsächlich.
Und wenigstens auch sowas wie Gameplay und nicht nur irgendwelchen schönen Trailer.
Gut, das sieht jetzt für mich jetzt als ein absolut Unkenntnis, der absolut keine Kenntnisse dieser Serie hat.
Jetzt irgendwie ein bisschen langweilig aus, aber ich glaube, da darf man sich nicht so viel reininterpretieren.
Das war eher so, okay, Champ.
Noch nicht, da ist der Hype Train, der braucht noch ein bisschen.
Oh, jetzt kommt bestimmt das Final Fantasy Remake, das nie fertig wird.
Oder auch nicht.
Doch, wahrscheinlich schon.
Nee, wahrscheinlich eher nicht.
Was ist das?
Ist das ein neues Final Fantasy?
Oder ist das was ganz Besonderes?
Okay.
Ja.
Man konnte da jetzt nicht viel rausbläsen.
Aber neue Spiele, ich bin immer ein Riesenfan davon, neue Sachen.
Und nicht der 85. Aufguss von irgendeiner Serie, da bin ich immer sofort dabei.
Kommt bestimmt Destiny oder irgendwie sowas.
Was ist das denn?
Es ist ein Spiel mit Katzen, das ist schon mal gut.
Ausgusspunkte.
Oh, das könnte was für mich sein.
Es schnurrt, hört ihr es?
Das war mal ein Game für mich.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, um was es geht, aber das war es für mich.
Also, ich habe keine Ahnung, was es geht.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, was es geht.
Das stimmt, der Xbox-Controller sieht, äh, der Playstation-Controller sieht...
Games used to be about these constant trade-offs between the artistic vision and technical limitations. With PS5, we're not going to be burdened like that. We're going to be able to realize our artistic vision a lot better. It's got a ton of horsepower, which is very easy to unlock and it's a machine that's really easy to develop on. The PS5 will present a paradigm shift as to what players will come to expect from gaming, will let us tell stories, make worlds, create gameplay that I
think will truly captivate the player and really surprise quite a few people. Please take a look at this new franchise for World Wide Studios, coming exclusively for PlayStation 5.
Was ist das? No Man's Sky 2.
WTF, was ist da los?
Anthem Rebooted.
Was? Returnal?
Ich fand das gar nicht schlecht. Chat sagt in die Tonne mit dem Game, ich fand das eigentlich gar nicht schlecht. Man hat zwar keine Ahnung was es ist, aber stimmig sieht es zumindest schon mal aus.
Sumo? Alles klar.
Wie war Pinata 3? Nee, was könnte das sein?
Ja, neues Little Big Planet, das wär was.
Da hätt ich das, das wird mir wirklich gefallen.
Auch die Sounds, die Little Big Planet Sounds waren auch so nice.
Chat, das ist mir in dem Fall wirklich wurscht, wie das ausschaut.
Hauptsache es spielt sich gescheit in dem Fall. Das muss ich zeigen. Nur weil es so eine Art Little Big Planet ist, heißt es ja nicht automatisch, dass was taugt.
Das letzte Little Big Planet was rausgekommen ist, hat mir auch nicht mehr so gut gefallen.
Das 1er und das 2er die waren nice.
Oder war das nur das 1er?
Was eine bescheuerte Überleitung zwischen Sackboy Adventure und dem Zeug.
Wie heißt dieses Fußballspiel mit Autos?
Rocket League. Rocket League meets Fortnite.
Wobei es ist eher Richtung Trackmania oder so. Okay, was auch immer.
Und die war verschnitt. Ich hasse, dass wenn Charaktere so gezwungen cool sein wollen.
Okay, ich bezweifle, dass man das, wenn das Game wirklich so ist, länger als eine halbe Stunde warten kann.
Destruction Allstars.
Royal fehlt da noch drunter. Destruction Allstars Royal. Das hat bestimmt Battle Royale Modus.
Hello everyone, my name is Josh Greer and this is my brother Mike.
We're from Ember Lab, a small team with a background in film and animation.
And we're very excited today to share with you the first look at our new game.
It's a story full of adventure and charm that has themes in personal growth and redemption.
So please enjoy.
I know you are kind.
You sensed the power that flows through this land.
Yet you do not fully understand it.
Hört sich ein bisschen an wie der Hanzo Sprecher.
Da hier ist auch schon Hanzo Light am Start.
You can help these troubled spirits.
You cannot hide your weakness from me.
You have no power here.
Denkt doch echt ein bisschen wie der Hanzo Sprecher.
Pikmin Pikmin.
Doch nicht.
Oder hat ein bisschen was von.
Also Grafik Style gefällt mir.
Bridge of Spirits.
Was ist denn jetzt los?
Das Dinosaurier.
Dinosaurier Emos.
What the fuck?
What?
Also so sitze ich gerade wirklich vorm Rechner.
Was?
Gut warum nicht?
Oh er stirbt.
Ach gibt es das auch noch?
Gibt es das auch noch?
Das ist doch uralt.
Ich wusste gar nicht wann es das letzte Ortwald gab.
2005 oder so.
Ne muss man nicht wirklich kennen.
Das ist halt so eine Art Lemmings Geschützsache.
Hauptsache ein bisschen noch nicht mal richtig.
Also Fake Dubstep im Hintergrund.
Oh ouch.
Oddworld Soulstorm.
Die müssen schon noch mal ein paar richtig.
Tokyo.
Warum müssen sie alle so gruselige Games machen in letzter Zeit?
Oh.
Da fehlt was.
Weeps out.
Okay keine Ahnung was da passiert und es ist wahrscheinlich gerendert.
Ist das der Slenderman Tokyo Edition oder?
Ich hab ich weiß nicht was da gerade passiert.
Face.
Ghostwire Tokyo.
Ich muss sagen sie haben sich sehr viel Mühe gegeben das Playstation Logo zu animieren.
What the fuck.
Was passiert die letzten drei Trailer hatte ich keinen blassen Schimmer was überhaupt abgeht.
Space X Undock Simulator.
Es fliegt.
Also fliegen also es bewegt sich.
Fliegen kann es ja nicht wirklich da.
Das geht zwar in Richtung No Man's Sky.
Vielleicht auch was in Richtung Kerbal Space Program oder sowas.
Aber auf der Konsole.
Also die Player Models sehen total beknackt aus finde ich jetzt.
Oder was auch immer das war.
Ich glaube ich habe das richtig gesehen.
Gearbox.
Okay was.
Die Trailer macht mich heute fertig.
Man hatte in keinem Trailer irgendwie Ahnung was überhaupt passiert.
Das ist ja so eine Art Mobile.
What fall Ach Moment ist das ist das zufällig dieses Spiel wo der wo der Game of Thrones
Autor irgendwas mit zu tun hat oder verwechsel ich das jetzt.
Da gab es doch auch irgendwas letztens.
Nee das war was anderes.
Das war Elden Ring.
Ah okay.
Komm mal ein schwarzes Loch.
Ja wer surft nicht einfach mal in so einem schwarzen Loch ist kein Ding.
Okay.
Das hat ein bisschen was von Journey oder oder von Flower.
Von welchem Hersteller ist das oder welchem Studio ist das.
Das ist eindeutig was Richtung Journey.
Von welchem Hersteller ist das.
Habt ihr was ich habe jetzt nicht aufgepasst.
Annapurna Annapurna ist Journey und Flower.
Dann passt das ja wie es ausgesehen hat.
Das ist das jetzt Hitman 75.
Hitman 69.
Slender Hitman.
Sie müssen alle so stylische Musik haben.
Orchester Soundtrack und Orchester Score ist überhaupt nicht mal angesagt.
Hitman 3 okay.
Ich habe außerdem im ersten Hitman kein Hitman gespielt.
Aber das erste Mal war extrem nice.
Ich bin Abraq hier von IO Interactive.
In Hitman 3 ist Agent 47 zurück für seinen intensivsten und professionellen Kontakt in seiner ganzen Karriere.
Das ist auch der dramatische Ende für die World of Assassination Trilogy.
Ich bin so stolz auf euch hier zu sein um euch ein kleines Glimpse von dem Spiel zu zeigen wo Agent 47 auf der Welt in Dubai ist.
Ich habe gar nichts gemacht.
Ich habe das letzte Hitman eigentlich jemals fertig geworden.
Die haben doch da auch so mit DLC Geschichten angefangen.
Und da hat es mich schon gar nicht großartig interessiert.
Ist das jemals fertig geworden.
Die haben auch so Season Geschichten gemacht.
Soll ich das mal machen?
Playstation Münzen sammeln.
Es ist auf jeden Fall nicht.
Astros Playroom.
Ich dachte auch erst ein bisschen an Mario.
Aber noch ein neues Playstation Logo.
Mr.
Babels.
An das gerade Pinguine die die Düne runtergefahren sind.
Was sehen wir uns da gerade an?
Das war jetzt zwar gut geschnitten oder?
Oh was jetzt hat gelagt Leute.
Oder von jeder Stream legt nicht das war Playstation Stream der geleckt hat.
Also man muss sagen ist ja viel Mühe ins Logo gesteckt.
Oh Sport Games.
Sportspiele.
Next Skip.
Es liegt nicht an mir Leute es liegt nicht an mir.
Guck mal es liegt am Stream.
Es liegt am Stream es liegt nicht an mir.
Das Stream ist RIP.
Oder leckt.
Oder von?
Komm wir probieren mal den YouTube Stream.
Zum Glück kommt gerade was was mich nicht im Bohnen interessiert.
Ah.
Okay schauen wir mal ob es vielleicht jetzt geht.
Das nicht natürlich.
Juckt mich.
Excellent.
Mit ihren Logos haben sie es aber echt.
Der Schwitz Simulator.
Eine Low Res Erdbeere.
Was ist das?
Die Qualität auf YouTube ist leider schlechter ja.
Sieht aus wie ein Mobile Game.
Was ist das?
Das waren Spare Ribs die im Sand lang gekrabbelt sind.
Die Subway Sandwich steht auch am Start.
Was?
Okay solange ihr Logo animiert gucke ich mal ob der Playstation 5 Stream auf Twitch wieder ordentlich funktioniert.
Nein der funktioniert nicht.
Wir müssen mal wieder YouTube gucken.
Was?
Schon fertig?
Jetzt kommt es.
Jetzt kommt es leider.
Ist das Elder Scrolls?
Nee oder?
Das ist nicht Elder Scrolls.
Es sieht nicht so richtig nach Dark Souls aus.
Oder doch?
Ist das ein Remake?
Das ist ein Remake?
Das ist ein Remake.
Voll in Hat.
Das hat was von Dishonored.
Erkennt Studios oder so?
Oder wie heißen die Dishonored Typen?
War das nicht Erkennt Studios?
Nee das waren die, gell?
Das waren die doch.
Ja klar das waren die doch.
Dann sind das die Dishonored Leute.
Das Movement war sehr Dishonored-mäßig aus.
Cyberpunk Dishonored.
Das Movement sieht cool aus.
Ist das VR?
Eher nicht.
Das ist nicht legit.
Wic Dishonored oder was?
Okay.
Ich wollte jetzt gerade gucken.
Ich wollte jetzt gerade gucken ob der Twitch Stream wieder funktioniert.
Okay, geht der Twitch Stream wieder?
Weil der sieht besser aus.
Nein, der Twitch.
Das gucken wir noch auf YouTube danach.
Wir müssen doch, der Sound spackt.
Noch mehr Horror-Spiele oder was?
Wie hat er da vorbeigeschossen?
What the fuck?
Der stand zwei Meter vor ihm.
Das hatte fünf FPS.
Das lief mit ungefähr fünf FPS was man da gerade gesehen hat.
Das hat echt hardcore geruckelt.
Das sieht aus wie Resident Evil irgendwie Leute.
Das ist Minecraft 2.
Village.
Okay, es ist so ein Resident Evil Spin-Off.
Einmal reicht nicht.
Oder ist das wirklich ein richtiges, echtes Resident Neues?
Das ist eigentlich ganz nice.
Schnell auf Twitch.
Wir sind schon auf Twitch PC lustig.
Das ist schon wieder Twitch.
Ja, das ist eine 8, Village 8.
Nichts anderes.
Was passiert da?
Rackmata, ahja.
Äh, irgendwie ist es, irgendwie sah das jetzt trotzdem ganz cool aus.
Ich kann mir nichts, keinen Reim drunter machen, äh, ich kann gar nicht mehr reden,
keinen Reim drauf machen.
Wie heißt das denn, Rackmata anscheinend, Rackmata, keine Ahnung was das Geschenk cool
aussprechen sollte.
Das wievielte Playstation-Logo war das jetzt?
Sony, ok, war es von Sony selbst, ist das jetzt Horizon Zero Dawn 2, ne oder?
Ich weiß nicht, dafür sind zu wenig Maschinen oder?
Das ist Aloy Sprecherin, ja dann wird es wahrscheinlich so sein.
Guck mal, eine Crap, aber, aber das müssten alles Maschinen sein, oh, anscheinend, ahhh,
jetzt ist klar, jetzt ist klar, aber die Animationen sind immer wieder huge.
Oh, mit Unterwasserstells.
Ja das ist echt wild.
Wie heißt Sch ROH?
Diese Mission ist für mich allein.
Wenn ich zerstöre, wenn ich verfehle...
...dann muss ich mich nur um mich selbst umsetzen.
Was kommt?
Aber was auch immer kommt...
Ich werde bereit.
Wo sie sind, egal wer sie sind.
Neue Erfahrungen, wie wir sie vorher nie hatten.
Mehr eckanische, interessante Charaktere.
Mehr atmosphärische, immersivere Welten für Spieler zu exploren.
Wir wollen die Welt erlauben, die uns nicht erwartet hat.
Und jeder kann nicht warten.
Wir können nicht warten.
Wir können nicht warten, um das Ende zu schätzen.
Es ist so spannend.
Wir sind wirklich auf dem Weg.
Wir sind auf dem Weg, um die Erleichterung zu machen.
Willkommen zu PlayStation 5.
Oder? Oder?
Ich mein, das wär so ein typisches Outro-Video.
Jetzt Konsolen reveal.
Sieht aus wie ein unfertiges Stück aus meinem 3D-Trop.
Ich mein, das wär so ein typisches Outro-Video.
Jetzt übertreibt man nicht, Sony.
Du hast noch nie ein starkes Konsole-Design gesehen und du hast schon Spiele gesehen, die nur mit der vollen Range von PlayStation 5s Features und Power genossen werden können.
Bei PlayStation glauben wir in generationale Transitionen und wir haben Jahre Arbeit gemacht, um sie zu machen.
Wir wollen, dass du die einzigen Vorteile von von einer Generation zu der nächsten genießen kannst.
Danke, dass du mit uns teilhabst.
Wir starten dieses Jahr später und wir haben viele mehr zu teilen.
Willkommen zu PlayStation 5.
Aber was auch immer kommt...
Aber doch gerade schon.
Oh, die Katze guckt. Die Katze guckt mich kritisch an.
Läuft da drauf was mit über 60 FPS? Tja, da bin ich auch mal gespannt.
Der offizielle Stream ist ja nur 30 FPS.
Okay, vielleicht kommt ja noch mal eine fette Sache hinten drauf.
Aber ich glaube nicht. Das sieht einfach zu sehr nach Outro-Video aus.
Das ist das Lüftergeräusch von der PS5. Der war gut.
Das Lüftergeräusch. Preis gibt's net. Mit den wahren PlayStation-Fan interessiert der Preis doch nicht.
Der kauft sich eh alles.
Okay, fertig. Leute.
Okay, es kommt doch nichts Großes mehr hinten drauf. Fertig.
Okay, ich muss euch ganz ehrlich sagen.
Wisst ihr, was mir am besten gefallen hat?
Also mir hat tatsächlich das neue Little Big Planet-Spiel am besten gefallen.
Wenn's was taugt.
Das letzte war schon nicht mehr so gut.
Grafisch war da jetzt nichts aufregendes dabei, sagt der Chat.
Ja, was sollen sie denn großartig machen?
Spiele sehen ja heutzutage nicht mehr einfach auf einen Schlag jetzt doppelt so gut aus wie vorher.
Was sollen sie denn großartig machen?
Die Webcam. Oh ja, die Webcam. Das war die überzeugendste überhaupt.
Ja, Journey-Nachfolger. Mal gucken, was da rauskommt.
2 Terapeit soll 599 kosten, okay.
Ist das nicht euer Viewer-Rekord? Keine Ahnung.
Ja, Pfund und Europreis wird doch wahrscheinlich relativ ähnlich sein.
Also, was soll ich sagen?
So hundertprozentig geschockt hat's mich jetzt nicht.
Habe ich aber ehrlich gesagt auch nicht erwartet.
Weil die letzten Sony-Präsentationen schon extrem Resident-Sleeper waren.
Die wurden bloß noch, finde ich, ne, ne, gar nicht.
Microsoft hat wenigstens Trailer gezeigt im Vergleich zu Sony früher.
Aber sowohl Microsoft als auch Sony waren beides echt ultra Resident-Sleeper bisher.
Also, ja, ich kann jetzt echt gar nichts großartig zu sagen, ehrlich gesagt.
Mach mal ne Umfrage zwecks Design. Für was? Ach so, von der Playstation.
Muss ich auch keine Umfrage machen, das ist doch komplett, also gerade das Design ist Geschmackssache.
Ich muss sagen, ich finde das sieht halt aus wie irgendein WLAN-Router im Endeffekt.
Also, da ist jetzt nichts wahnsinnig geniales oder so im Design dabei.
Das sieht halt aus wie so ne, wie ne Hardware-Kiste mit Zeug drin.
Nicht mehr ganz so eckig wie früher, aber es ist auch nichts weltbewegendes.
Ja, Spatzgranate, das rechnet sieht ein bisschen aus wie Alienware.
Warum auf einmal weiß, mich würd's nicht wundern, wenn's die in mehreren Farben sogar gibt.
Es ist doch grad im Trend, dass man Sachen mit mehreren Farben anbietet.
Und das kannst du bei der Konsole, sieht ja auch so aus, als könntest du die Seitenteile ganz gut tauschen.
Zumindest beim Herstellen, da relativ einfache, unterschiedliche Seitenteile dran machen.
Und dann gibt's die dann, gibt's dann in Pink, in Weiß, in Schwarz, in Silber, in was auch immer.
Könnt ich mir gut vorstellen.
Wieso kein Skyrim? Du kannst drauf wetten, Skyrim kommt noch.
Skyrim kommt für jede Plattform.
Und außerdem ist das Ding ja rückwärts kompatibel für die PS4.
Gibt's Skyrim überhaupt für die PS4?
Fritzbox-Station, es sieht ein bisschen aus wie ne neue Fritzbox, ja das stimmt.
Nix zu Battlefield 6, nix zum neuen CoD, nee gab's nix, ja.
Wie ist eure Meinung? Man hat nicht allzu viel gesehen.
Die Konsole sieht aus wie ne Fritzbox, in Weiß.
Ähm, au! Ah!
Ich find ja, geh ich um einen Nas gekommen.
Wie gesagt, ich hab ja letztens übelst die Nas am Gelände angehauen.
Aber jetzt voll den blauen Fleck.
Autsch.
Ähm.
Mag es jetzt nach dem Review, welche Konsole sagt dir im Moment mehr zu?
Weder noch, ich kauf die mir zum Release diesmal eh nicht.
Ich werde mir diesmal, Leute ihr kennt mich, ich sag das jetzt und wahrscheinlich kauf ich sie mir trotzdem.
Aber ich werde mir diesmal zum Release keine Konsole kaufen.
Ich hab mir sowohl die PS4 als auch die Xbox One zur Release gekauft.
Ich hab hier noch, hier liegt er.
Leute hier liegt er.
Der Controller.
Day One 2013 steht drauf.
Und ganz ehrlich, ich hab diese Konsolengeneration fast nie verwendet.
So gut wie gar nicht.
Sowohl Xbox als auch Playstation.
Ähm.
Und.
Die Zwischengeneration hat es eh verkackt.
Mittlerweile ist ein PC langlebiger als eine Konsolengeneration, wenn man sich die Zwischengeschichte anguckt mit PS4 Pro und Xbox.
Im paar Xbox hab ich schon wieder vergessen, wie das Ding heißt.
Xbox Benamung ist ja eh jenseits von Gut und Böse.
Preis? Nein, Preis wurde nicht genannt.
Die Switch hab ich auch nicht so viel benutzt, weil für die Switch gibt es kaum gescheite Games.
Das wäre so ein bisschen das Nintendo Problem.
Es gibt so vier, fünf Sachen, die sind cool.
Und Rest ist auf jeder anderen Plattform besser.
Außer man möchte natürlich die Switch mitnehmen.
Dann ist es gut.
Ja, das würde mich auch mal interessieren, ob man wie laut die Playstation ist.
Die neue.
Ob sie das gut gekühlt bekommen.
Aber das nächste, was bei mir erstmal ansteht, ist weder eine Konsole, weder eine Playstation oder eine Xbox zu release,
sondern wenn AMD eine neue CPU rausbringt und Nvidia eine neue Grafikkartengeneration, dass ich mir einen neuen Rechner hol.
Ist nicht so, dass mein Rechner schlecht ist, aber mir juckt es schon seit Ende letzten Jahres in den Fingern.
Ich will mir einen neuen Rechner holen und es lohnt sich aktuell einfach noch nicht.
Choose my name, ja, kann sein.
Da ist ein Headset jetzt dabei, dass es erträglich ist.
Aber wahrscheinlich ist das eher für ein komisches 3D-Sound-Gedüns, was wir da das letzte Mal angepriesen haben.
Ich hab keinen Ryzen, nee, ich hab noch einen 8700K.
Ich hab letztes Jahr überlegt, ob ich mir nicht einen Ryzen kaufe, aber ich bin dann zu dem Schluss gekommen, es lohnt sich nicht.
Jetzt einen neuen PC zu kaufen.
Sobald es die neuen CPUs von AMD gibt und sobald es eine neue Grafikkartengeneration von Nvidia gibt, wird gekauft.
Ich brauch was Neues an Hardware.
Wisst ihr, früher hab ich mich geärgert.
Da hab ich ganz scheiße.
Ich muss mir alle zwei Jahre einen neuen Gaming-Rechner kaufen, so zu Zeiten, wo ich noch kein Geld hatte und nichts verdient habe und keine Kohle hatte.
Und jetzt, wo ich genug Geld hab, sag ich, scheiße, ich kann mein Geld nicht ausgeben.
Genau das umgedrehte Problem.
Für Warzone neuen Rechner, nee.
Warzone läuft auch so ganz gut.
Warzone ist halt an manchen Stellen verbackter Crap.
Aber wofür brauchst du denn einen neuen?
Haben.
Ja, wunderbar.
Jetzt wissen wir Bescheid oder auch nicht.
Warum sind da so viele Monka Esse?
Huge Monka Esse.
Ich soll den Chat ein.
Ach stimmt ja, den Chat können wir wieder einplenden.
Da ist der Chat.
Ja, ja, ja, Leute, ich bin ja ein bisschen enttäuscht, bin ich ja schon.
Ich hab jetzt nicht so den Wahnsinns-Hype erwartet.
Aber ich hab gedacht, das ist vielleicht der ein oder andere richtige Knaller dabei, wo ich sage,
Scheiße, damit habe ich nicht gerechnet.
Aber das ist geil.
Es ging so.
Es war jetzt nicht total scheiße.
Ja, es war schon okay.
Was hältst du von VR?
Es gibt zu wenig Spiele.
Der eins, jetzt mal ernsthaft, VR-Spiele außer Half-Life gibt es ja kaum was.
Und Resident Evil, Half-Life und Resident Evil.
Gibt es ja kaum wirklich richtige Must-Have-VR-Spiele, wofür es sich lohnt, so etwas zu kaufen.
Und das Einzige, wofür es sich lohnt, ist, falls es Leute gibt, die sich VR-Porn angucken wollen.
Für die mag es sich eine VR-Brille lohnen.
Aber ich habe es bis jetzt noch nicht eingesehen, mir eine 3D-Brille oder eine VR-Brille zu kaufen,
für ein Game, was ich spielen will.
Choose my name, tue dir keinen Zwang an.
Und VR-Chat, ja, wenn es einem gefällt.
Das Einzige, was ich weiß, oder das Einzige, was ich kenne von VR-Chat, ist Ugandan Knuckles.
Ansonsten ging das voll an mir vorbei.
Weiß man schon, ob die Digital Edition ohne Laufwerk billiger werden wird? Weiß man nicht.
Ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass sie so symbolisch billiger wird, so 10 Dollar oder so.
Oder sie hat mehr Speicher und ist teurer.
Oder was auch immer.
Warum wird man nicht Alexi-Bexi empfohlen? Das kann ich mir nicht geben.
Hast du eigentlich Windows-LTS? Nö.
Man kann die Playstation 5 wohl auch flach hinlegen? Ja, gehe ich auch fort aus.
Es wäre auch ziemlich bescheuert, wenn sie das nicht ermöglichen würden.
Außer sie wollen, dass die Leute ihre Konsumzellen nicht mehr erledigen.
Das wäre auch ein bisschen schade, wenn sie das nicht ermöglichen würden.
Aber ich bin mir sicher, dass sie das nicht ermöglichen würden.
Man kann die Playstation 5 wohl auch flach hinlegen? Ja, gehe ich auch fort aus.
Es wäre auch ziemlich bescheuert, wenn sie das nicht ermöglichen würden.
Außer sie wollen, dass die Leute ihre Konsole permanent kaputt machen, weil sie sie umschmeißen.
Was ist denn heute? Heute ist Donnerstag. Morgen ist ja gar kein Aufwachen-Stream-Chat.
Maman da. Irgendwie habe ich im Kopf gedacht, es wäre heute Samstag und morgen ist Aufwachen-Stream.
Morgen habe ich frei, ja. Morgen ist ja gar kein Sonntag.
Morgen Früh-Stream. Wie viele von euch am Urlaub?
Oder umgedreht gefragt, wer muss von euch arbeiten gehen und wer hat morgen frei?
Arbeiten frei. Ich nicht. Wehtschicht. Igitt.
Arbeiten-Brückentag. Also die meisten müssen wohl...
Nee, ich würde sagen halbe halbe. Halbe halbe mit dem Trend, dass wohl ein bisschen mehr arbeiten müssen als...
Home-Office zahlt sich keinen Urlaubstag aus. Bei mir war es so, ich musste 60% meines Urlaubs verplanen und da habe ich noch einen Tag genommen, den habe ich gebraucht, um bis 60% zu kommen.
Spätschicht. Weil das nichts für mich wäre. Frühschicht ist besser.
Also wenn ich Schicht arbeiten muss, müsste, würde ich immer Frühschicht machen, dass ich früh gehen kann.
Das mache ich ja jetzt im Prinzip auch schon fast. Ich stehe ja 5.45 Uhr auf, dass ich 15.30 Uhr heimgehen kann.
Ansonsten würde ich erst 17.30 Uhr heimgehen, das wäre mir viel zu spät.
Nachtschicht-Zulage. Dann ist es was anderes.
Bei uns der Support bekommt auch am Wochenende Zulage. Und an Feiertagen. Und nachts. Und am besten an Feiertagen nachts.
Da streiten sie sich immer, wer die Schicht machen darf.
Ja, ich gehe eher früh ins Bett und stehe früh auf und bin dafür auch früh wieder daheim.
Anstatt zu umgedreht.
Ja, mehr gibt es zur Playstation 5 jetzt echt nicht zu sagen. Wir müssen mal abwarten, was da rauskommt.
Also ich werde, wie gesagt, ich werde mir weder die Xbox noch die Playstation 5 kaufen zu Release.
Ha, Eiskäuter. Richtig gute Idee. Big Brain. Big Brain.
Ich nehme aber auch immer Dezember komplett frei.
Dezember bin ich immer komplett daheim.
Ich habe Spaß gemacht, dass ihr mit mir sagt, Cowboy, das ist sehr schön, sehr, sehr, sehr nice.
Nee, glaube ich nicht, dass ich, nee, nee, ich glaube, ich bestelle mir keine PS5.
Also vorbestellen werde ich die PS5 auf jeden Fall nicht. Exzellent ist das genau.
Vorbestellen werde ich auf gar keinen Fall und ich gehe auch ziemlich sicher davon aus, dass ich mir diesmal nicht zu Release kaufen würde.
Werde.
Weil ich habe, ich habe mir die anderen beiden zu Release gekauft und ich habe sie nie verwendet, so gut wie nie.
Richt Monarch S.
Mal gucken, ob sie Lüftergeräusche in Griff kriegen.
Battlefield 6 könnte ein Reboot sein.
Im Prinzip ist jedes Battlefield ein Reboot.
Halt mit einem gemeinsamen Gameplay-Kern.
Hat Microsoft schon was vorgestellt? Ja.
War doch letztens erst diese Xbox-Trailer-Stream.
Den konnte ich aber leider nicht streamen.
Ich glaube, da hatte ich keine Zeit an dem Tag.
Jaja, die haben irgendwelche Trailer vorgestellt.
Da war aber jetzt auch nichts dabei, was mich groß geschockt hat.
Oh Leute, ich bin müde. Ich glaube, ich gehe jetzt gleich pennen.
Ich glaube, ich gehe jetzt pennen.
Das war so geil. Lass noch mal angucken.
Wann kommt commentary auf YouTube?
Ich habe ein richtig geiles Warzone-Gameplay, das ich hochladen wollte.
Okay Leute, also wir sehen uns dann. Mal gucken, vielleicht morgen früh schon.
Bis dann. Wir sehen uns. Machts gut.
Wir sehen uns. Machts gut.
>>>>>>> Stashed changes